Yesterday he said anybody celebrating this violence is a valid
target. And now he's going to go look through a list of people
who are celebrating the violence. I I don't think it takes much
to put two and two together here. Never let up the pressure.
Uh never ever ever do that. Uh keep this pressure up until these
people lose their jobs. And then after they lose their jobs,
then take a break, relax, pat yourself on the back, wait for
them to get another one, and then do it again. If your reaction
was to grin and celebrate, you must be destroyed. >> You
shouldn't view them as people. You shouldn't view them as a person
with a political disagreement from you. Uh these are violent
animals that are trying to destroy uh the last good thing that
we have, which is the open ideas of political discourse. And
they're celebrating murdering people for doing it. You must be
identified. You must be isolated. And you must be eradicated
from our society. Uh-huh.
1 hour ago. Asmin Gold video. These people are evil.
Let's look. We've got way more people who are ready to traumatize
themselves by reading Blue Sky.
Awesome. Awesome. Aren't you Aren't you guys down for this? Like
this is like opening up um like Stormfront when it existed, right?
That that was what it was called. And just going on there when
like some like progressive died and just like traumatizing yourself
looking at like terrible people's opinions. I don't understand
what use this serves in the world, but >> and today we're
going to look at some of the interesting users on you would never
believe it. Blue sky. >> I dude it's so embarrassing. This
should be embarrassing for everybody. Everybody who does [__]
like this should be so embarrassed. Okay, guys. I'm uh I'm going
to go look at this place with really offensive opinions to me.
Stormfront, isn't that Oh, that's the superhero. Uh,
wait, what is it called? Stormfront. What was the white supremacist
site that uh Andrew England wrote for? It was Stormfront, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, anyway,
it's like going to the most offensive places you can and you
just like read opinions that you know are going to upset you
for the for the Daily Stormer. The Daily Stormer. Oh, I don't
know why I Oh, that's different. But what was there was a message
board. There was a message board that wasn't the Daily Stormer,
right? Am I crazy? They named Stormfront after Stormfront the
Daily Stormer. Okay, there we go. There we go.
That's right. And uh I don't know how this keeps happening, but
yesterday after Charlie Kirk was brutally murdered, he was shot
in the throat, uh bled out in on stage in front of everybody,
including his own family and his children. um the number of people
in the games uh industry who decided to go on to social media,
particularly Blue Sky. A lot of these people, you have to understand
that many of these people have already been run off of Twitter
because there's a level of discourse and negativity that they
can't really deal with. So the only place that they can really
exist is on effectively a reservation like Blue Sky where their
opinions are protected and they're allowed to be vitriolic and
nobody's allowed to tell them that they're wrong. Well, that's
why we're making this video. We're going to be looking at some
of the different people that after the death of Charlie Kirk
decided to and I'm not really going to be going through. Everybody
goes is going to draw the line at a different place. I just want
to make it clear that if I saw like a trans person who was going
on to like pull to read their comments about like some trans
discourse that was going on, I would have the same criticism
for them, okay? Like you are why go to the exact place where
the most offensive things are going to be said about you? You
are a total [__] All right? I
I'd have that same energy for anybody doing something like this.
It's totally it's totally moronic to do. This is just silly.
Here's where I draw the line. I personally have a problem with
people that are celebrating him being killed. I don't have a
big deal if somebody says I don't like him or I never liked him
or something like that. But for the people that are celebrating
for him being advocating for future violence and saying that
it's a good thing, I think that's what crosses the line for me
and I think that's what crosses the line for any reasonable normal
person. And so anyway, uh, >> by the way, I just want to
point out when you put together Asenold's past two videos, is
he not just like saying, um, dox and kill these people. Like
this video is just dox and kill these people, right? When you
put it together with the video from yesterday, he's just going
actually go dox and kill these people. Anyone you can find, dox
and kill them. That's explicitly what this video is about right
now. >> Uh, we're going to go through a number of people.
And the first thing I wanted to start out with to >> No,
no, Metal Bacon. No, that's not what he's doing. Yesterday he
said anybody celebrating this is a valid target,
right? Anybody celebrating this violence is a valid target. And
now he's going to go look through a list of people who are celebrating
the violence. Like I I don't think it takes much to put two and
two together here >> today. Is that maybe you guys remember
this from the beginning of the year? Uh it was a content uh it
was a big content year. I would say that. And people might have
forgotten, but there is a person who decided to uh advocate for
your local MAGA. This was a Blizzard employee. And I want to
say that after the video that I made on him and a lot of other
people made on him, this person lost their job and effectively
has ruined their life. And I want nothing more than for the exact
same thing to happen to the people in this video, too. So, I
hope that after you guys see these individuals and you see what
they're advocating for, you'll be able to go out and tell their
employer, "Hey, you this is actually nuts. This is crazy."
If this is the vid I'm thinking, it actually has full names.
>> Dude, it's so crazy where these people are at. Uh, Wendy,
thank you very much for the gifted sub. I'm sorry. I'm going
to watch this video cuz I think somebody has to be out here like
actually saying this guy's insane. All right, he's like totally
lost it. I And the sad thing is I hope he's got friends because
there is a decent chance that his father's health is very bad
and he is like lashing out right now. Um, and I don't know that
he's got friends who are capable of like taking who he was as
like a sort of provocator and remaining friends with him who
are able to identify that he's like crashing the out right now.
like this is not good. This is not good. But I think his friends
are like Techone and other people who are like going off in this
totally extremist direction because the thing that made Asmin
Gold so like kind of hard to deal with is he always kept a good
idea of where the lines were and how he shouldn't cross those
lines. And now he's sitting here being like, "Yeah, I don't give
a [__] about those lines. I'm crossing them. [__]
all these people. I want to I want to go after these people."
And it's like, dude, that's you're not going to last for very
long. I don't think Asmin Gold can last very long doing this.
>> You know what? Maybe I'm not comfortable funding a video
game that is employing people that are advocating for the brutal
murder of a person in front of their family. And uh it's absolutely
insane, but it's also not surprising. And so anyway, we're going
to go through some of these. Obviously uh you know, I put out
a post about Asmin Gold is just straight up doing the Dan Sman
playbook right here, right? Except Asmin Gold's got a way bigger
audience. Oh boy. >> The Kirk's assassination. We'll look
at pretty much who these people are. We'll start off with this.
Uh these are people Dennis. Let's look at this. And this is also
on Blue Sky. I'm 65 and Vans Blue Sky Social. Uh sound effects
associate at Bungie. So Bungie, you know the game that's trying
to make Marath >> on Oh, I'm not going to talk about that
right now. >> I guess they were too busy. He's doing sound
effects, not visual effects. So maybe he actually has to do his
job rather than just copy pasting something off of Twitter. But
anyway, you've got somebody like this who's advocating for. And
again, people might think that it's not a big deal. Oh well,
these people aren't making any statements themselves. These people
aren't really saying anything uh that is that extreme. Here's
the reason why it's a big problem. The reason why is because
it creates an ecosystem and an environment where the actual extremism
and the actual radical behavior is feeling comfortable. It it
feels comfortable in an environment where you have this blloze
uh passive acceptance of it and you have people that are just
basically
complicit with it but they're not. >> I feel like this
guy's going to pull up like LinkedIn for people. I think he's
going to do it. Maybe he'll just go through blue sky. Honestly,
if these people put their full name on their blue sky, that's
a little that's a little
>> Not openly saying it. They're just privately doing it
or they're just privately voicing their support as well. And
well, I guess in this case, it's not private anymore, is it?
And so anyway, we have a associate producer at Bungie who is
liking and promoting tweets uh that are celebrating the death
of a uh person being shot in the neck uh in front of their family
and bleeding out profusely on the stage in front of millions
of people. And so good job Bungie. Uh really really uh really
good winners you've got here. I can't wait to play Marathon.
Uh I I thought that my expectations for the game couldn't be
lower, but somehow Dennis has managed to fulfill uh you know
or uh by the way this is like the death nail for a lot of creators
when you start doing like this, right? Like I think I don't see
how you go back to doing like like video game content after this.
I don't it's like so weird to to go and do this is so just bizarre
to me. Oh man. >> See those X >> I guess he's just
got more money than God, right? Like he's just got money. He's
just like, "Yeah, fuck." You could say, "I've got another one
also. Uh, Kelly, senior producer at Sucker Punch, amateur cosplay
armor, DND enjoyer, source of corgi pics, they and she." Okay,
so we have also, and you're going to see this word uh this this
uh term sucker punch a number of times. Uh we're not talking
about the action, but um we are talking about the company. This
is the company that makes the game or that is making the game,
Ghost of Yoai. uh Ghost of Yoai. And this is also important to
keep in mind is that the voice actress for the game for the the
character itself uh has gone multiple times on record making
the most deranged stupid comments like defunding the police.
Uh, I think that you don't get like I just think this is always
the death nail for a career when you go and start getting like
explicitly like revenge political like politically like vengeful
is I I think there are creators who do this and they just like
start to fall off entirely.
Like this is not going to be commensurate with the other with
the other content they've done. I feel like this to me just seems
like it'll be the death nail. But who knows? Maybe not. It might
just be the deathnell for the gaming stuff. He might go totally
into politics or something after this. He can still play games,
by the way. I just think the people who come for the gaming content
are going to move on to other creators. >> She's just your
typical like libtard insaniac [__] right? It's not
really that complicated. But um what what it really indicates
is that there's a culture in this company and there's a culture
in this environment uh where this type of radical violent behavior
and language is normalized. you have multiple people at the company
that are >> By the way, I don't like Okay, I don't like
that he's Maybe this is um different or something. I don't know
exactly what he's doing for like who is he looking up? Cuz I
swear to God there's like a bunch of names, but I'm not seeing
what they did. So, what kind of due diligence is he doing before
he goes and like outs these people? Is he going to make sure
that they're like actually doing something crazy? Like they're
saying crazy or is it that they like liked one? It would be so
to me if like these people like mislike the post kind of celebrating
Charlie Kirk dying because they're in these circles or something
and then they're getting like doxed and asminold saying you got
to get them fired. I don't know. I don't know what's going on
indicates is that there's a culture in this company and there's
a culture in this environment uh where this type of radical violent
behavior and language is normalized. You have multiple people
at the company that are all saying these things and we're going
to get to the other ones too. Uh this is another person here
also that uh works at the company. And so you can see right here,
obviously, this is them retweeting or uh posting uh something
that they did with the game. And then right after that, I hope
the shooter's name is Mario so that Luigi knows his bro got his
back. And I've been noticed that Twitter has noticed me from
I've been told that Twitter has noticed me from across the room.
Well, we certainly have. Uh we absolutely have. And I think that
these kinds of comments are absolutely disgusting. This is a
person that works at a massive game company and they're openly
advocating for on public platforms and promoting and celebrating
the murder of a random person. Uh this is disgusting. It's really
disgusting. And in my opinion, I >> He's a self-admitted
accelerationist. I don't know what he thinks accelerationism
is. What is he I think. But to be clear, that's like what Asminold
does most of the time, right? Asold just very very often shows
that he has no idea what anything he says means. >> I don't
think that it should be tolerated. And that's the reason why
I'm making this video. I think that everybody should try to message
uh anybody that works at this company uh anybody who you know
like any sort of PR any management uh you know anything like
that let them know that uh you don't want to support a company
that employs people that celebrate the murder of uh of innocent
people just for exchanging ideas uh this is a disgusting disgusting
thing to do and you can see also and I think this is a systemic
problem at the company itself Whenever you have three people,
the voice actress and then these two other people that are also
doing this, I think that it's very obvious that this company
has been infected with the same kind of moral rot that many other
video game companies have unfortunately been affected by. And
so you have also uh ze they them they them always a very good
indicator of uh mental uh awareness and normality. Um a producer
at Magic the Gathering. So, this person works at I'm assuming
Wizards of the Coast. Um, and uh they're working at Magic the
Gathering Arena previously also at Wow.
Wow. What are the coinc Wow. What are the odds of that? What
a coincidence. And so, what you've got here, >> okay, I'm
trying to look. Okay, just to be clear, I went and looked at
this uh this person from Sucker Punch.
>> Maybe they took stuff down. >> Rean Ruben donated.
>> All this from a dude who relied on a rat to alert him
that it was morning. >> Yeah. I am literally looking. Maybe
they maybe they cleaned everything up. But yeah, I just looked
at this. I don't see posts about Charlie Kirk here. I literally
don't at all. Do you view like uh post interactions or something?
Do they show I don't know if I'm allowed to look at or view post
interactions. Do you see likes on Blue Sky? Maybe they maybe
they just deleted or something. I guess this is again another
person who is celebrating this type of violent behavior. And
I think that again uh people need to make their voices known
and make them heard that this is just simply not acceptable.
This is not normal. This is not what average people want. We
don't want to have people that are openly making statements and
calls to violence like this or celebrating calls to violence
or actual violence like this uh making our products. It's disgusting.
And I know that some people would maybe consider and say, "Well,
this is something that could be a little bit like cancel culture."
And I want to say that it absolutely is. Uh 100% is. When you
do cancel culture, it's soy and destroying America. When I do
cancel culture, I'm saving America. And it's awesome. All right.
That's that just is what it is, guys. Okay?
No bad tactics, only bad targets. Dude, there's no way we have
to go watch this again. Okay. >> Hey guys, it's me again,
and it's been a little while. Um, just before I get into the
main topic of the video, I want to explain why there haven't
been any videos. My dad has been in the hospital for the better
part of a week now. Uh, very to be used against people they disagree
with. I think that's fine. But whenever you have people that
are saying things like 8647
or anybody who's advocating for any form of extrajudicial justice
Yeah. Yeah. extrajudicial justice and basically vigilante justice
on people who they disagree with politically. Um, you have to
realize that all of those people, I think, have made themselves
acceptable targets. And I think that there's a lot and millions
of people out there nowadays
that see that. And I think that that should be extremely worrying
for them. Like, you just put these two videos together and I'm
sorry,
you put the two of these videos together and I feel like that's
got a very unsettling implication for me. Okay. I don't know
if he can't connect the two videos. If they're like totally right,
this should scare them. Okay, they should be they should actually
be scared right now. Fact is that these are the same types of
people who would lie about you and uh make up things about you
and try to destroy your career and destroy your reputation for
disagreeing with them on something political. But now whenever
it's happening to them, they're the victims. Well, if you want
to be the victim, it's time to earn it. I think you have to accept
the context that he didn't say these things together. He may
not be directly tying them in his mind. Okay, I don't care. I
literally don't care. This guy's got millions of subs, millions
of viewers, extremely loyal viewers. He has like a movement of
some of the most disaffected people in America. Like, I'm sorry.
He needs to be responsible for that. Yeah, he absolutely needs
to be responsible for that. You don't get away with You don't
get away with doing this. This is crazy. Also, what what is also
crazy is how long it's taking for this press conference to start.
Okay. Can I get whoever can we can we get Asmin Gold to go put
up the the you know full docs of the person who set up the this
press conference timing. Can we Asmin Gold, can you do me a solid?
Okay. They should be in fear for wasting my time right now. That
I said that very dryly. That's a joke. That's a joke. We don't
like violence. We don't like violence. I think also here's another
thing is that if you work at one of these companies and you have
one of these individuals that works at your company, you do have
a dis a recourse to this and that's calling and talking to HR
because the fact is that HR does not operate in your best interest
and it doesn't operate in their best interest either. it operates
in the best interest of the company. And when you have people
that are making public statements and calls to violence and celebrating
violence like that, they're creating a hostile and an unsafe
work environment. And anybody who works in HR or anybody who
works inside of any sort of corporate environment will tell you
that that's something that just can't exist in a corporate environment.
There's a reason why we have levels of decorum. And >> uh
that is No, no, no, no. Hold on, Ron. I don't think that's that
far off. If these people are making tweets about how Charlie
Kirk deserved to die and they put sound effects associate producer
Bungie in their thing and it's like clearly them. I do think
you shouldn't attach if they have a disconnect between their
online person and their like real life person. That's maybe I
don't think they should be punished. But I think like if you
literally put your job title in there, you're associating your
job with the social media profile. You're a [__]
[__] >> And there are some levels of HR that
make sense. And so if you work at one of these companies and
you have a person like this doing it, make sure to talk to HR
and let them know how uncomfortable you feel that there's a person
who's working at your company who might want >> they're
just liking the the >> want to advocate to have you because
you disagree with them. Tell them that it >> I'm not going
to watch ours too afraid to come into work. Tell you that tell
them that you know you don't know maybe you're going to file
a lawsuit. You feel unsafe at your workplace. And honestly, here's
the important thing. You should feel unsafe because these people
would justify violence against anybody who disagrees with them.
And just because you think you know them doesn't mean that they
wouldn't do the exact same thing to you. And uh this is them.
This is the game that they're making right here. And you can
see that they've made no statement about this. Uh now, let me
ask you a very simple question. If these people made a degrading
comment towards uh the trans community, for example, or towards
uh the black community, for example, do you think Sucker Punch
would have immediately fired them and made a statement? I think
so. Absolutely. But for some reason, these >> Well, I mean,
it would require somebody doing like a public there would need
to be some public hubhub, otherwise they would never know about
it, right? These companies aren't just checking all of their
employees social media to see if they're saying anything bad.
>> People are protected. And the reason why they're protected,
he's not shown anything yet. lot of other ones at the company
that feel the exact same way that they do. That's the only logical
reason that I have. And I think that at a certain point Sony
or uh somebody needs to step in, whoever owns this company needs
to step in and root out this disease before it kills the entire
company because I do think that it will have a tremendously negative
effect on the game. And you can see this right here. Uh this
is a post that Sony made I guess it was uh a couple of days ago
about Ghost of Yoai and you can see a thousand comments on this.
Your senior dev at Sucker Punch is a violent leftist etc. And
these are more comments here. Uh never let up the pressure. Uh
never ever ever do that. Uh keep this pressure up until these
people lose their jobs. And then after they lose their jobs,
then take a break, relax, pat yourself on the back, wait for
them to get another one, and then do it again. >> Yeah.
Destroy these people's lives. I'm not gonna be happy until these
people >> And that's the only way. >> Literally,
this is literally I hate to use the cliche, but this is like
you either die the hero become like live to see yourself become
the v villain. Yeah. Yeah. The villain. Dude, what?
This is just every single thing like the soy lefties did when
they went to cancel people, right? It's all of the things at
the same time. He's just become the thing he said was terrible.
>> That you should treat these animals. And that's exactly
what they are. You shouldn't view them as people. You shouldn't
view them as a person with a political disagreement from you.
Uh these are violent animals that are trying to destroy
uh the last good thing that we have, which is the open ideas
of political discourse, and they're celebrating murdering people
for doing it. And as soon as that starts happening, I don't want
to know what's next. And the worst thing is that I already do.
And I think you do, too. >> Okay.
I misheard that. I misheard that. I'm going to play it again.
>> The open ideas of political discourse. And they're celebrating
murdering people for doing it. And as soon as that starts happening,
I don't want to know what's next. And the worst thing is that
I already do. And I think you do, too. And so anyway, uh, we've
got more. >> Okay, never mind. He might he might just be
saying that they'll kill people after >> these years. Regation
is not enough for me. I hope he tanks the student. >> Sucker
Punch senior dev celebrates Charlie Kirk's death. Ghost of Yoai
is dead to me now at Sucker Punch prod. The shooter's name is
Mario and uh so that Luigi knows his bro got his back. I mean
that is just a joke. Uh is it tasteless? Yeah, absolutely. But
it is a joke. That is a joke 100% right. Sorry.
God, I
>> and carrots keep >> I'm just I'm sitting here,
dude. It's like it's hard to get excited for this. Like, if this
was a joke about a trans person keeping themselves, they would
all say it's funny and they're like, "Yeah, it's tasteless."
But like, it's just a joke, dude. He shouldn't lose his job for
it. That's 100% what it would be. I
>> quiet the studio deserves I understand why a lot of
people at these companies don't speak up which is why I suggest
that if you work at one of these companies uh please make sure
to go to HR uh go to HR and file these complaints legitimately
with them. There are certain legal things that they have to do
and in some cases these people will pretty much lose their job
for sure uh if enough people are discussing it. And you have
also some people make comments like this. Um, it's wild how the
woke right like Asminold, uh, Grums are showing themselves to
be what they hate, authoritarian freaks that want to censor and
silence anybody they despise. Um, yeah, I do. I I do. I think
that any >> Yeah, I did that. Yeah, that's who I am. >> Anybody
who's advocating for uh people over speech like this uh should
be censored. Absolutely. And uh this is just normal. Uh >> all right.
Anyway, I don't know that there's really anything else to do.
We just got the video of him dropping off and we've we've looked
over the pictures and stuff. Doesn't really seem like there's
any new information here. It's over for Hassan. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Elon Musk. Did Elon Musk declare open season on Hassan [__]
Breaking numerous clips of Hassan [__] calling on
his viewers to right-wingers after or going viral after saying
or the slaying of Charlie Kirk with calls for his immediate arrest
for fermenting violence as Twitch refuses to take action. Right
angle news >> on there. Okay, you need to be gutted. I'm
sick and tired of it. left-wingers,
liberals, you need to be showing your opponent's guts on there,
okay? You need to be gutting them. You need to be shanking these
and letting their >> Dan would retweet this. Uh Dan did
retweet this, did he not? >> Letting their intestines just
ride on stage. What the [__] is this [__]
man? Slice them up. Slice them and dice them. What the is this?
You cannot have a bigger layup. You could not have had a bigger
layup than a horrible candidate like Hershel Walker. Sure, he
was prepared very well. And Hershel Walker actually You think
he's calling for people to actually Hershel Walker here? Like
it seems like on the stage he thinks like the opponent should
walk over and gut Hershel Walker.
That's what he's arguing for. Not great optics. I mean, I'm sorry.
It's pretty clear that's not what he's actually asking for. Right
now, you could say, "Hey, don't use that kind of language. That's
amping the that's amping the uh the temperature." But then again,
this is what two years ago now, two and a half years ago. >> Had
a good
thing. We do need to make sure we do. We got to keep >> Oh,
this is a Dan clip 100%. There there's no chance anybody other
than Dan Saltman puts Dan Clansancy in this clip to try to pressure
people >> attracting younger viewers that you know grow
up on Tik Tok you know when they're 8 n 10 11 12 even though
they shouldn't >> and three it's like all here is that
just a Dan Clancy clip out of nowhere >> Tik Tok you know
when they're eight n younger viewers that you know grow up on
Tik Tok you know when they're 8 n 10 11 12 even though they shouldn't
three. It's like all here now. This guy is down. He's dead. These
guys are like >> unfatally wounded.
>> They're not even like They're not even running. They're
not even like cowering and running away and screaming in fear.
There's like, "Okay, well, they did it. We got our shots. Okay.
Is this guy done?
Okay, we brought the >> It's called shock, you idiot.
It's called shock. Anything that happens, I mean, like, holy
[__] guys. If you live in Florida, I have an opportunity
for you. If you want to earn $100,000,
let me know. Jesus Christ. >> Flag. So, we can put that
>> Mike is such a >> for the bleeding part, assuming
he got shot and is actually right
>> This guy
Bel driver. I'm going to kill you with my AR-15.
Like, that's what the that's the type of messages they were leaving
in this dude's uh of this dude's office. And he's resigning.
Like he's literally this is his last g. So So I think that people
are a lot more radical. It's hurt >> Dude, this is this
has to be this is so poorly put together. >> So So I think
that people are a lot more radical. It's hurt poor people that
they can they they can afford housing in Berkeley. I don't know
how that >> Well, my understanding is that the property
owners who have choose just not to rent it at all.
It's explicitly
the Dan Saltman clip. This is, by the way, this is the one I
said. This is like from what, five, six years ago.
Let the let the streets run red with their blood. >> That
they can they they can afford housing in Berkeley. I don't know
how >> my Well, my understanding is that the property owners
who have properties there choose just not to rent it at all.
>> Yeah. Kill those. Murder those in the street. Let the
streets Let the streets soak in their [__] red capitalist
bloods. Dude, >> by the way, those aren't political opponents,
just to be clear, right? Right-wingers. This is not a call to
right-wingers. That's not what that is. At best, you've got,
just to be clear, a call to apparently Hershel Walker by his
opponent on a live stage for a debate. Uh-huh.
I don't Landlords don't even suck. I just This is like an embarrassing
clip. Oh yeah, then one of the calls to violence is on Destiny.
I don't Okay, this is just very >> I'm sick and tired of
it. >> I thank God that um in terms of like trying to do
these totally dis disinginguous cancellations, it's Dan Saltman
who is leading them all of the time. Cuz if somebody competent
was trying to cancel Hassan and had had started with the same
things that Dan started with, if anybody remotely competent had
started that campaign and carried it through, Hassan would have
been Hassan would have been done. But it's Dan who is a total
who has no idea how to actually run one of these campaigns. If
it was anybody other than Dan, anybody remotely competent, Hassan
would be done. He'd be in the dirt. Okay. But it was Dan mixing
in random clips that have nothing to do with anything. Taking
it way past the point anybody could believe him so that other
people had to call him out for being a total [__]
It's just Dan [__] this up from moment one over and
over again. Yes. Yes. He totally all of his priorities on everything.
It's Yeah. It's but you know if you're Hassan you got to thank
God it was Dan and not somebody competent. Jesus Christ. Okay.
All right. Back to the Asminold video. Back to Asminold calling
for these people to be. Let's go. For sure. Uh if enough people
are discussing it. And you have also some people make comments
like this. Um it's wild how the woke right like Asminold uh Grums
showing themselves to be what they hate. Authoritarian freaks
that want to censor and silence anybody they despise. Um yeah
I do. I I do. I think that anybody who's advocating for uh killing
people over speech like this uh should be censored. Absolutely.
And uh this is just normal. Absolutely. I I that's the line on
advocating killing people really. Like I'm not a huge fan of
celebrating this kind of stuff or even joking about it, but like
unfortunately I was told that comedy is back. Okay. Comedyy's
legal again. That should include [__] like this.
I don't there there's this this trick that a lot of people like
this like to play which is they try to use your own language
and use your own morality against you. Uh these people don't
care about freedom of speech. They don't care about censorship.
They don't care about any of that. They're simply trying to weaponize
your values and use them against you in order for them to fulfill
their own goals. And so every time that they try to make an appeal
to your own values,
>> hold on. Apparently we got a we got another Nancy Mace
clip. Nancy Mace, she's on one today, guys. >> Like enough
is enough. And now I have to deal with real safety concerns.
It sounds like the shooter was or prot
and just because I want to protect women that I'm worried about
getting murdered. Are you kidding me? This is it's out of control
and and enough is enough. And I'm going to double down on this.
I'm going to be more vigilant than ever. I'm going to be louder
than I've ever been. >> It's kind of gross. >> Until
this stops, it's got to stop. >> By the way, that's just
like I'm sorry. This person is Oh, I don't have the video up
anymore.
The uh the actual person, if that's the assassin. Okay, that
is the assassin in the videos. That's not a trans person. I'm
sorry. It's just not. It's not. bone structure, way too masculine
to be a female to male trans person. Um, way too much muscle
mass and the ability to accurately at 200 yards makes them not
a female to or sorry, male to female transerson. Just clearly
not a trans person. Sorry, it's not. It's just objectively not.
Could be ambient gender flu. No, nope. Nope. Nope. They're not.
They're just not objectively not. >> You should ask yourself,
do they hold these values? And if the answer is no, then you
shouldn't take it seriously because this person is simply trying
to use your values to subvert you and take advantage of you and
to push their own agenda and to hurt you. And so never listen
to this. Never play into this game. Never even acknowledge that
uh that there's any validity to it at all. Uh these people don't
care about freedom of speech. It's not as bad as bring it up.
They're trying to co-opt the person who does care about freedom
of speech and make that person act against their own best interest.
But um anyway, uh we've got also, you know, this is me. I almost
put out the call for fine game devs mocking. And uh there's another
one here. Uh this is the voice actor for Duke and Genchin Impact.
Uh this I hope they receive the same care that the average American
citizen would get in the same situation. Really? So they're just
going to fall down and die. Uh, somebody gets shot in the neck
like that with their blood like spurting out. Uh, >> dude,
that's not even that's not even a crazy statement to make. Okay,
this guy advocates against like universal healthcare. I hope
he gets average American healthcare. Like >> there's no
there's no health care. You're not you're not coming back from
that. At least not anytime soon with the medical care that we
have now. And so anyway, Lisa, >> yeah, that the point
is Charlie Kirk would be against that. >> Uh, somebody
gets shot in the neck like that with their blood like any validity
to it at all. Uh, these people don't care about freedom of speech.
The only time they bring it up is whenever they're trying to
co-opt the person who does care about freedom of speech and make
that person act against their own best interest. But um, anyway,
uh, we've got also, you know, this is me. I was almost put out
the call for fine game devs would get in the same situation.
Really from now. I just I don't I'm like trying to think of like
something interesting to say here. This guy's just like lost
it. He's lost it totally. I don't I have a hard time like even
making this like fun at this point. It's not like he's like a
little off. It's not like he's a little He's just like out here
taking like I thought these would at least be like jokes about
Charlie Kirk dying or like laughing at Charlie or being like
I'm so psyched Charlie Kirk died. But they're like the most mundane
things that he's freaking the out over.
at least not anytime soon with the medical care that we have
now. And so anyway, Lisa came out uh Lisa goes out doing what
he loved, being a bigot. Uh yeah, of course, you have more comments
like this, more people like this. And police is permanent. Every
post you make goes out to the public firehouse, captured by someone
somewhere. The delete button doesn't do what you think it does.
And so anyway, we have a lot of people obviously that are starting
to say stuff. Live by something something. So, she's obviously
trying to make a statement of live by the sword, die by the sword.
Uh, this is what and and I think that this is a very revealing
statement, and I think this is going to be the last comment that
I'm going to look at here, is that um this statement is actually
extremely revealing because what it's saying is that from her
perspective,
living by the sword is the same as being >> somebody was
a physicist and you knew that one of their theories they were
proposing was incorrect. Would you just not state that because
they died? Like if that's literally their profession. I feel
like their professional contributions are different from like
having empathy for them as a as a like a human being. You don't
have to love Charlie Kirk to You don't have to love Charlie Kirk
to have empathy for him and his family at the time of his death.
And you don't have to hate Charlie Kirk to criticize his political
speech. I don't think his critical like as long as you're not
implying he's it's okay to him as long as it's like couched significantly,
right? Oh, obviously this is not saying he's allowed to be shot,
but I disagree with you calling him a moderate. I think that's
misleading. Totally acceptable speech. That's not that's not
celebrating his death. That's not saying that's not saying it's
okay. That has to be allowed. >> Speaking out and being
able to uh you know like express your opinion on certain things
should be met with the equivalence of deadly force. And that's
really what these people want. Uh they want to bully uh push
fight and if it comes down to it kill you if you disagree with
them. And that's why whenever somebody does do something insane
like this, all of these people tried to do mental gymnastics
about why it was somehow justified, normalized, okay, accept.
I'd expect that we're going to actually fall or sorry, we're
going to actually find he did a mass call for tweets and all
he got was three to four apparently. But I'm telling you, we're
going to find this more and more where people are going to shift,
okay? as it becomes more and more obvious that this person's
not a leftwing shooter or that they like are, how should I put
this, that they're not like a um man that they're not purely
a leftwing shooter, they're not just like a leftist transloving
crazy or something. Okay. I think that as it becomes more clear
that that's going to be the case. No, we don't know that, Wendy.
I'm saying this is what I would bet on. As it becomes less clear
that they're like or as we move further away from like them all
believing 100% that this is like a trans shooter or a protrans
shooter. Okay. As we move further away from that, we'll see them
focusing on responses more and more because they won't be able
to point to the actual violence anymore. Don't let people get
away with that, okay? Don't let them do that slight of hand where
they're going to go, "Oh, well, it's actually more about the
left's response to Charlie Kirk getting shot." That's actually
the big shut. No, that as soon as as soon as Gold started running
with this line of thought that it's like all lefties and and
they forced this to happen. They're the reason Charlie Kirk got
shot cuz they people knew that they would celebrate this violence.
As soon as he ran with us and he started As soon as he ran with
that and started like doxing people and saying that these people
need to live in fear now he's it's already sealed, right? Don't
you don't let that go. You don't let him forget that. He's out
here like painting targets on people when he doesn't even know
what happened yet. Is this going to be less of a problem in a
week? No, it's not. But you might understand who the shooter
is and what their motives were and you might not make an act
of yourself >> or something one way or another. Uh the
fact is that uh no uh live by the debate die by a gunshot wound
in the throat. No, I don't really think that makes a lot of sense,
does it? But it doesn't sound as good as these, you know, vapid
uh, you know, like yas queen comments that people like her make
on blue sky that Mr. Ro, you shouldn't cheer for the shooter
getting away. Trust me, as being a shouldn't change how you feel
about the shooting. Just pursue your own like principles. Don't
don't like change don't go, "Oh, these people are really gross.
I want like worse things for them." [__] that. Don't
let a Don't let a [__] like this change how you actually
think about the world. >> Have absolutely no push back
because they're on their own protected reservation away from
anybody whose opinions could be different than their own. And
that's the reason. And also those are the only people that are
still left on the platform. And soon if with enough enough effort
and enough work uh we can have enough of these people uh removed
from our uh our media, removed from our public discourse and
uh removed from any sort of positions of power where they can
exercise their completely
uh totally deranged viewpoints and worldview. And so anyway,
I want to let you know that this is definitely not uh the only
amount of them that there are. I'm sure there's plenty more.
And so if you want to
express and show any of these other people and you want to post
one of their uh their comments or anything like that, um I would
recommend anybody to go on over to Roach Ranch. Uh this is a
uh comment right here. Um sorry, not not comment, a community
right here that I made on Twitter. Uh, I do not really moderate
this at all. And if you guys want to post the
>> to spread misinformation about recent elections, vaccines,
and racial stereotypes, yes, it's actually flat. also known as
the Asenold Twitter >> Different public comments uh that
are being made by these different developers or these different
people that are working in media uh celebrating this and uh collectively
we can uh contact their employers, contact the people that are
around them and have them get fired from their job and do not
for even a second think that this is not fair. It is absolutely
fair. These people have been doing it to people like me for the
better part of 5 years and it's time the shoe goes on the other
foot. They're disgusting. They're celebrating violence and there
shouldn't be any space for this in any sort of a polite societ.
Oh, it's like the whole stop anti-semitism thing again, dude.
Ah, I can't stand people who do this [__] These people
really mean on Twitter. So, we actually need to dox them. We
actually need to dox them and report them to everyone. I'm like
over here. I don't think it's sticking to um excuse me. I don't
think it's sticking to just people who are in the games industry
either. Oh, they've got a new one. They've got Charlie's
We got Charlie's murderers.com. That's just a big doxing list
of anybody who celebrated Charlie Kirk's death. Wow. Cool. There's
like Yeah, somebody right at the top. Dude, it's so it's so crazy
amazing, man.
>> But yeah, anyway, >> [__] this [__]
is like kind of black pilling, I'm not going to lie. Crazy things
going on over at Sucker Punch Productions.
Really, really crazy stuff. I uh you know, with that many weirdos
and uh and freaks working at the company, I wonder what this
game's going to be like. I kind of don't want to know, but actually,
I kind of do. I think it'll be great content, but for all the
wrong reasons. So, >> what if this game is just good? >> So,
anyway, guys, uh that's about all I've got for today. Uh I did
promise I would go through all of this, and we've gone through
all of this. So, >> wasn't Ghost of Sushima good? I thought
people really like Ghost of Sushima. >> Thank you all very
much. I really appreciate you watching and feel free to join
the Twitter community or to join Reddit or anywhere else, but
Twitter community is the best and most uncensored place. Reddit
is very censored uh for a number of reasons uh that we have to
>> Oh, he said he previously said the game would be good
and he'd play it, >> right? We just have to follow the
Reddit rules. Twitter doesn't have those same rules. So, if you
guys want to talk about this issue more and bring up more people,
uh, feel free to go over to the Twitter community and we can
mobilize from there. And hopefully we can put uh, you know, everybody
together and actually achieve something for a good cause. And
don't ever think that this kind of stuff doesn't matter. Uh,
this kind of stuff has led to a lot of people getting fired,
which is the exact reason why I'm doing it. Hopefully, it'll
happen again. So, anyway guys, thank you all so much for watching.
I really appreciate it, and I'll see you all as soon as I can.
He's actually advertising doxing. And don't forget, he's not
just advertising doxing. Okay. He's not just advertising doxing.
>> Saying things like 8647
or anybody who's advocating for any form of extrajudicial justice.
Yeah. Yeah. Extrajudicial justice. And basically vigilante justice
on people who they disagree with politically. Um you have to
realize that all of those people I think have made themselves
acceptable targets. And I think that there's a lot and millions
of people out there nowadays
that see that and I think that that should be extremely worrying
for them. Should be terrifying. But the reality is that they
have created that environment themselves through their own >> want
these people terrified. We want these people to be valid targets.
We want these people
>> actions through their behavior and through their own
words. You reap what you
think. >> Hold on. >> What are we looking at? Rob
J. Hammond. Thank you very much for the gifted sub. Oh, I have
not chilled at all. Guys, guys, if you like the content, go ahead,
throw a couple subs, throw a donation, buy a TTS, okay? Do whatever
you want to do. You can sub on kick. You can sub on Twitch. Don't
forget twitch.tv/jstlk.
That's where the primers go. Okay, if you guys have a Twitch
primer if it's just laying around, not getting used, go ahead,
throw it over here.
All right. >> Hopefully someone archives this. Yeah, I
hope so as well. >> Would really hope. Oh, Rob J. Hammond.
I don't know why that took so long to come through, but thank
you for the gifted sub again. Same gifted sub. I I think people
will be archiving this. I don't think I don't think you're going
to get to take this down. Oh, yes. I remember that. Verain. Yes,
I was going to check that out. I think he's been live for a while.
Listen, we can uh I got food, so we can drift off of this guy
for a little bit. Draft off of this guy. Give me a quick second.
Who's the Who's the biggest live streamer on Rumble right now,
guys? I wonder who it is. Oh, wait. It's not Wait, what? Oh,
do they still have him like censored from the front page? That's
crazy. people saw >> I was just like 170,000 viewers right
now casually you know >> life is like a >> you know
how it is guys >> I don't think these events process it
it did not >> okay let's check this out >> even everybody
you are watching America first my name is >> Good evening
everybody you're watching America first my name is Nicholas Jay
Fuentes we got a big show for you guys tonight is usually what
he says >> Nicholas Juentes
I am joining you tonight under some very dark circumstances is
uh normally I like to say we got a great show for you tonight
and I think it's going to be an excellent show but of course
the news is unbelievably tragic tonight as you know you're all
gathered here my head volume up for you guys now here's the thing
the interesting thing about this tonight will be is he going
to try to do like some kind of center pivot he's kind of been
softening a little bit around the edges recently I don't know
how much he can do it I don't know how much he could ever get
away with it but there's a lot of that Charlie Kirk audience
that would look to him in some way like he's very popular right
now.
Nick did hate Charlie Kirk. Yes, >> I think it's going
to be an excellent >> of course the news is unbelievably
tragic tonight. As you know, you're all gathered here. We're
going to talk tonight about the death of Charlie Kirk. And even
saying that out loud, the words
are still I think I think he's going to do we're Christians.
turn the other cheek that like you have to you guys have to pull
it back. You guys have to be the bigger people. We're better
than them. We're going to show that we're better than them. We're
going to show that we are that we believe what we actually say
we do. Right. I think he's going to go in that direction cuz
I think that direction is somewhere is somewhere um not a lot
of conservative influencers are going. He's got a big enough
base that he can go in a different direction than other people
and a lot of people will follow it. >> Still very surreal
uh and disturbing.
I said this last night and I meant it as I watched the chaos
and the tragedy unfold yesterday afternoon
and I know everybody else feels exactly the same way. It didn't
feel real. That's the characterization I keep seeing from everybody
on Tik Tok, on Instagram, on Twitter. People have been profoundly
affected by this
and we're not sure why. Uh and hopefully we can talk a little
bit about maybe why that is. But as I said yesterday, I like
many of you, I got the alert from a friend of mine who I believe
was either at the event or had friends at the event at UVU in
Utah.
A friend of mine texted me and said, "Charlie has been shot."
I said, "Charlie Kirk?" They said, "Yes." And we watched it unfold
live. We're still getting updates. We don't know exactly what
transpired.
And again, we'll get into some of that as well, some of the uncertainties
and unanswered questions. But I am devastated
and uh legitimately
affected
and struck viscerally. Such a sensational video images. Such
an unspeakable horrible tragedy. And and I literally had to take
a day to collect myself. Normally, uh you know, this is a current
events show. I'm live every night and I discuss the news of the
day and I've been there through many of the big developments
over the years. Same day, January 6, Trump assassination attempt,
the elections, the pandemic. Uh but this one was different and
I think everybody feels that way about it. It felt like a nightmare.
That's the only way that I can accurately describe it actually.
Uh throughout the entire day yesterday, I just could not process
it. It did not sink in. It still hasn't fully sunk in. Like I
said earlier, you say those words, the death of Charlie Kirk,
the assassination of Charlie Kirk, the murder of Charlie Kirk.
I watched his Wikipedia page go from Charlie Kirk is to Charlie
Kirk was. It doesn't feel real. It feels like a nightmare that
will never wake up from. And I say that as somebody who was not
even a fan, not a friend, and actually an adversary, a foe. I
can only imagine
what his friends, his colleagues, uh, and and especially his
wife, his young children,
you can only imagine what they're going through. And so what
happened yesterday is still so raw and so sensitive.
The country is profoundly affected. At least some of it is. We'll
talk about that, too. And so tonight, I'm going to try to to
the best of my ability
carry out my responsibility. I believe and I think you know that
I'm somebody that many of the young people, young conservatives
are looking up to.
I have a lot of credibility with the far right, the radical right.
And throughout his career, Charlie Kirk always characterized
me as a troll. I don't say that with any malice at this point
in time, but that's what he said.
And many in Turning Point USA said that I and my
are nihilistic. We only want destruction. And >> oh, I
actually muted for a quick second, but I haven't been saying
too much. >> I think that I have an obligation
>> uh to the country. I think I I have an obligation to
God. I think I have an obligation to all of you. I think I have
responsibility to prove that that is not true. That's not about
me. But now that it is the morning after, the day has dawned
where Charlie Kirk is now dead at the hands of some unknown attacker,
it is our responsibility, mine and all of ours, to step up and
to get serious. To the extent that politics was fun or we took
it lightly, I think we now realize it just got very real.
It's been real. People talk about a civil war. They say a war
is coming. Some say we're already in one. We have an obligation
now uh the leaders,
the spokesmen, the men, the young men, the elderly men, we have
an obligation to lead. And I want to start the elderly men. Okay,
dude. >> Before we get into any of it by saying this, just
as a general note, I've been around now for seven or eight years.
That's not a very long time, but it's long enough. I've lived
through a lot of these events. Charlottesville, January 6th,
the Groper War, many things. And I know that in my career, I've
made a lot of mistakes. I've done things I regret, said things
I regret. I've made a lot of the same mistakes twice. And I've
been lucky because I've lived and I have this platform and I'm
able to speak to all of you in spite of that. And I think maybe
one of the reasons why is because I have been afforded the opportunity
to learn a lot having been in the center of dissident right-wing
politics, far-right politics, in the center of this cultural
moment, whatever you want to call that, as an archetypal
disaffected young white man, angry young white man, Trump supporter,
however you want to characterize that. I have been in the thick
of it for a very long time and seeing many crises
and tragedies
and things that we
cannot explain, things that are difficult to cope with. I will
say first, as I said, as a general note before we move on, it
cannot be overstated
how important it is in a time like this to put our intentions
in alignment with the will of God. Everybody's very emotional.
Everybody is whipped up and rightfully so, justifiably so. People
are furious. I don't know that the left fully understands that.
I don't know that normies fully understand that. People are absolutely
beside themselves. I've never seen the right-wing more angry.
I'm trying to think of how Trump would handle this. Trump is
I feel like he's got to go a different way, but he does have
to you have to acknowledge the anger, right? You have to acknowledge
the anger. Say that you're angry. You're furious. Maybe even
say like you think I'm not angry. think I'm not ready to go do
some crazy. You think I'm not thinking about that? I am. That's
a human thing. And then pull it back to your actual morals. >> More
furious.
And this has been building. Here we are today, the day after
Charlie Kirk has been. But we're starting here in the middle
of the story. It's been going on for over a decade. And these
things compound over time and they accumulate. And I, like everybody
else, recognize that this could potentially be a watershed moment.
This is a ripple effect. We may look back in time and see a chain
reaction, an inexurable chain reaction that leads to nothing
other than destruction, devastation, bloodshed, misery. I don't
think it's crazy to say millions of dead bodies. And we must
have the prudence. We must have the confidence in our convictions,
in our faith in God. This is the test. It's easy
to believe in prayer when things are easy. It's easy >> Dude,
Rumble is not built for this kind of chat at all. Rumble is not
built for chat to move this. >> Believe in God, mercy,
forgiveness,
temperance
when things are easy. It's when things are hard, when they're
confusing, when we feel justifiably angry, wrathful, prideful.
That's the test.
That's when it counts. And that is when mature people, and I
recognize the folly in me saying that. I don't consider myself
an extremely mature person. I think I'm a frivolous person in
many ways. But it's an obligation for all of us to grow up now
and recognize the gravity of the situation we're in, the peril
that we're all in. And we have to ask ourselves, what are our
intentions? We have to set them intentionally. We have to set
them in alignment with God, with the gospel. We have to think
not just about the present moment and what we're feeling, but
about the long term, the good of our country,
the good of our fellow countrymen, both the people we agree with
and disagree with, our children, our progeny.
And we have to think about that moment before God. We have to
think about our moment before God in judgment. And we're asked
about that golden rule. We don't save ourselves. We approach
God with humility. We approach the judgment as weak,
as mortal,
fallen, before we take up arms, before we relish in our anger
and sit with it, sit with our rage and resentment and fuel it
and get into these loops, feedback loops. I think it is so important,
and this is why I said last night I wasn't going to do a show,
and I really meant it. I and I think everybody needed one night
at least to sleep on this to pray and to pray not. Hold on a
second. Is Nick actually Christian or grifting? Um,
it's tough to tell. He He knows how to be Christian. The issue
is basically my big issue with Nick and his Christian beliefs
was I I feel like some of his stuff borders on idolatry. Like
I said that um if you guys watched when the Fentes rally 2 happened
with all the the gody gold and how he's like I I think he basically
compared himself to Jesus in that in that rally. Like it's um
yeah. So I think he understands Catholicism. He understands how
Catholic people think. I think he's got a lot of sincere beliefs
but there's also an ego there that is not he's not humble in
the way like a Christian probably should be. Not just for the
repos of Charlie Kirk's soul and for his wife and for his two
young children and for the people affected in his organization
and for the people that were closest to him but also to pray
for the wisdom, the strength, the prudence,
the humility,
the fortitude to approach this in the right way. Because how
we respond to this tragedy, like all of these events, like all
of the persecution, all of the suffering, the anguish, it will
define us. It will define our country. It's it is life or death
here. And what I am urging at the very outset of this at the
minimum
is caution. Let us not be hasty. If you're thinking of picking
up arms, put them down. And if you can't be convinced altogether,
put them down today. Put them down tomorrow. Let us be cautious.
Let us >> This is why he's going to hit every single note
correctly. And this is exactly why he's dangerous. He could hit
every note correctly. >> Be prudent. Let's think. Let's
get right. Let's get right with God before we act hastily. And
the reason I say that I have come to this
reaction over many years seeing many crises is because not only
is there a spiritual dimension to all of this and the devil uses
our emotions against us, uses our best intentions, our best inclinations
against us to doubt our faith in God that God is both just and
merciful. our faith in God that he will deliver the vengeance
that we are told is not in our hands. Trust in his plan and not
create our own. It's not just for the spiritual reasons but also
for the political reasons. Ask yourself, we all recognize this
is a watershed moment. We're never going back from this. This
is the shot heard around the world. literally
one shot, one an international incident
a and a outpouring of both love and affection in the vigils that
you see for Charlie Kirk across the country, but also in anger
and resentment, hatred, people ridiculing his death, all of these
different things. It's important also to understand that politically
it is in crises like these when we become instrumentalized
by forces outside of our control when we take our eye off the
ball
and I don't want to be too explicit at this moment now but when
we take our eye off the ball
because of something so sensational because of something so emotionally
charged that's why they do these things that's why supernatural
as well as societal forces do these things or capitalize them
and take advantage of them. And people guided perhaps by good
intentions or righteous indignation become unwitting instruments
of forces beyond their control, beyond their understanding, they
become pawns in a larger game. And so
in order for us not to be agents of evil,
a supernatural evil, a worldly evil, in order for us not to be
instrumentalized by sophisticated and powerful forces that would
use this tragedy to manipulate society for its own ends. In order
to save our souls from the kind of wrath, anger,
that will surely land us a seed in hell. I would first say before
I say anything else, especially to the young people, the adolescents
that I and I understand how you feel, lay down your arms. Those
that live by the sword will perish by the sword. Remember what
Christ said. This is our cup to drink from. All of us. Death,
suffering,
martyrdom in some cases, it's all part of it. It's all part of
life. And not to be fatalistic and not to minimize it, but as
a Christian, we can't always talk about I just have to point
out the bots are like losing it over here. I'm going to stop
it. Like has full pages of just the >> prosperity gospel.
We can't always talk about making money or prosperity and the
kumbaya. We also have to talk about the other side of things
which is that we have a Lord and Savior that was crucified on
the cross by our sins
by our own iniquities. All of us. And not just the killers and
the scoundrels and not just the obvious
obviously evil people but also sometimes ourselves. assuredly
everybody, you and I, everybody.
So, we have to take those things into consideration. We have
to be humble about these things. And that's just a word of caution.
That's that's me trying to do my best to be responsible here
before we
get into the larger
So, we'll talk about it now. As you know, Charlie Kirk was assassinated
yesterday afternoon doing >> Just want to point out, okay,
that the actual human being that we're listening to for like
the the first time here is not opening this up by going and talking
about how this affects him, right? He's not starting with, "Guys,
I want you to think about how this affects me." He's going with
like, "Dude, it's it's terrible what happened to him. Prayers
to his family, right?" Like, that's where that's where he's going
with his >> one of his change my mind events, his college
tour. It was one of the first stops on his new college tour in
Utah. Started out like any other day. And I'm sure for him it
was just another day. He's done this hundreds of times. He got
dressed. He went to the event,
talked it up with uh politicians and friends of his said, "This
is going to be a great event. Filmed Tik Toks." And all of a
sudden, a shot rang out. He died, I assume, instantly, although
some of the details are uncertain. People fled. He's now gone.
And the first thing I want to say about it after the word of
caution is this. Of course, uh, as I said, I was not a friend
of Charlie Kirks at all. I didn't like him. He didn't like me.
We had a lot of differences ideologically, politically, and we
fought viciously. He did a lot to stifle my career uh, and suppressed
me in many ways. And I antagonized him a lot and mocked him and
ridiculed him and attacked his credibility. He was my opponent.
But I would never wish death
upon him or anything like that. And Charlie Kirk never had a
kind word to say about me in his life.
Now that he has died, I'll say some kind words about him. Although
I didn't agree with him. I considered him a part of the political
establishment. In many ways, I considered him part of the problem.
In spite of that, it is undeniable
that he was a towering
figure in American conservatism. That's undeniable. He was ambitious.
He was a hard worker. He did things I cannot do. A lot of people
said after his passing, I saw some people make oblique references
to it. They said, "Well, if Charlie Kirk was assassinated, now
the far right will step up." I don't know that there's anyone
that could fill his shoes. I don't know that there's anyone that
can do what he did. He died at 31 years old and left a legacy
that many people could not achieve in many lifetimes. Uh, how
do you not just tune this out? Like, what do you mean tune it
out? I I mean, I'm just listening. I'm interested in the response
because I think there's there's a massive power vacuum within
the conservative movement in America. The conservative movement
in America is like driving your country towards kind of like
destroying the entire planet right now. And one of this is like
a top general being taken out. And like suddenly there's a massive
power vacuum. And I have no idea how that gets filled. So, I'm
watching eagerly to see how people are responding. Obviously,
if you know anything about the conservative movement, okay, I
I'll actually be honest. I didn't know I didn't know like how
popular, you know, Charlie Kirk is most popular, maybe even almost
uniquely popular with extremely religious people, right? Like
he is he's religious people love Charlie Kirk, right? That's
Nick is approaching from the angle of I'm going to talk to the
people who like this guy. That's who he's doing this stream for
right now, right? How much do you think Nick and Ben Shapiro
grow from this? Um, viewership wise, not that much because there
aren't a lot of TPUSA viewers. Charlie Kirk didn't do streams.
Charlie Kirk had real influence. Charlie Kirk could pick up the
phone and talk to Donald Trump whenever he wanted to. He had
the ear of the White House. That's the power vacuum that you
don't that we don't know how it's going to be how it's going
to be filled. But you need somebody with some media training,
some media savvy, right? So, I'm just interested to see how things
shift here.
>> Thank you very much for the five gifted. That puts us
up to Oh, it's pretty close. I'll I'll calculate, but we might
be like one sub away from another hour on the stream, guys. >> Three
hours a day. He went and faced down his enemies in debate. >> He
would take on almost any challengers. I say almost because he
wouldn't debate me, of course, but >> nevertheless
would debate anybody anywhere, stare them down, and people don't
know how difficult that is.
He would sit there for hours on any subject
and then he would return home from the command center and direct
the largest youth organization, the most ambitious project in
conservative politics maybe ever. And he did it all before the
age of 31. An absolutely brilliant,
sharp, fierce warrior
for his values and his beliefs. And as I said, I disagreed with
them strongly. I'll make no bones about that. And that hasn't
changed. But you have to admire that this was a fighter.
This was a worker. This was a champion. And above all else, maybe
this is what I respected about him the most. We had our disagreements.
Where we did agree is that he would go to these college campuses
and proclaim the name of Jesus Christ. And ultimately, that is
why he was killed. Everyone will be persecuted. Okay. I mean,
he totally lost me on that one. I don't I think it has way more
to do with supporting the current administration. I think it's
way more likely it's from supporting the current administration,
but >> for the sake of Jesus Christ, anyone, everyone
fighting and winning that spiritual battle for Christ and for
his kingdom will be persecuted for his sake. And I don't believe
Charlie Kirk was any different. We disagreed on much, but we
agreed about abortion. Oh, he's talking about like metaphysically
like that is what led to him being I I think he might be talking
about like not directly but like metaphysically like sort of
by being a a like a man of God. That I think that may be the
point he's trying to make. Yeah. We agreed about feminism. We
agreed about many of the other moral social ills of the country.
And when you look at his most vicious detractors, the people
celebrating his death now. >> Okay. The people because
most vicious detractors that is just objectively Nick and it
always has been like for as long as they both existed. But he
means people celebrating his death. Okay. >> Possibly probably
the gunman that him. They hated him because of his defense of
Christian morality. He wasn't killed necessarily perhaps by a
socialist
or by someone who disagreed about his position on fiscal policy.
And this is something I think we all need to take into account,
something we need to be aware of and notice. The most vicious,
hateful opponents of the conservative movement of all stripes,
they are the ones championing transgenderism,
which goes by another name, mutilation of the body, a disordering
of the soul. Come on, man. Nick, this is where I'm gonna have
to start pointing out things like the fact that Nick loved being
in a bunch of different Twitter group chats with a bunch of trans
people and like joking around with them, talking to them, willing
to go on like podcasts with them. Okay, I come on, man. It's
the proponents of abortion, which is some form of child sacrifice
at the minimum infanticide. These are the most vicious, violent,
hateful detractors
>> of even a moderate conservative like Charlie Kirk because
he stood up for those biblical values. I'll say it better. Christian
values, Christian morality, for Christ himself, for the truth
incarnate. And for that, I consider him a true martyr. And I
hope his reward is in heaven. I'll also say he was clearly a
loving father, a loving husband. He was beloved by millions of
people. That is obvious. And although I do not count myself among
his fans, it was clear that millions upon millions of decent,
earnest, good people, Christians, patriots, they did love him
and he belongs to them. And out of respect for them, I say that
Charlie Kirk was a good man. God bless him. And despite our differences,
our past debates,
I consider that over. And I pray for the repose of his soul,
for his family,
for him. That's Charlie Kirk. Now, aside from that, it's important
to say that it's obviously a horrific thing. And I think everyone
is blaming trans people after this. I I don't understand why.
I don't I still like I think to me there's like I don't even
know if there's more than a 50% chance it was somebody who even
supported trans people.
Like I I actually don't see the evidence for that yet. And people
are so obsessed and so certain that that's what it is.
It's it's so bizarre to me. Like it's not bizarre in that I understand
why ideologically they're doing it. I don't understand why people
are like putting their credibility on the line to declare it.
That what is so striking about it is because it became so real
in that moment. It was such a graphic
video. This is somebody that we felt like we all knew. I never
met him. I never shook his hand. I never spoke with him. I saw
him and I I've been at arms length with him before, but I never
knew him. But to us, he was imminent. He was ubiquitous. He was
all over Tik Tok making content. He was synonymous with campus
conservatism.
And like many personalities, politicians,
the kind of medium that he used, social media, live streaming,
we all developed a parasocial relationship with him. And whether
we loved him or we hated him, he was known to us. And other people
that we know die, but they die in hospitals or they die when
we're not looking.
He was publicly executed suddenly, unexpectedly
in front of millions of people on camera. And we saw >> uh
guys, two steps away from two hours in the stream, just so you
know, >> on graphic detail, his life end that way. I think
that's why >> this is having such a profound effect on
>> and the reason that it has shaken everybody to their
core and in some ways >> sorry one step away my bad >> unconscionably
has become divisive >> somehow is because there are a lot
of decent people still left in this country and maybe they're
right-wing and maybe they're leftwing and maybe they voted for
Trump and maybe they didn't but in that moment when they saw
this young man this young father this young husband, a good man,
a congenial by every metric, a positive, cheerful person, a generative
person, someone who loved America, fought for what he believed
in. A I I don't think Nick say you see it at the edges. I don't
think he thought that about Charlie Kirk. He's tapping into,
you know, the the love bombing that Charlie Kirk's getting now
that he's dead. Okay, that's more what it is. He doesn't believe
that. Nick believes that Charlie Kirk sold America out, >> right?
He thinks Charlie Kirk sold America out to Israel. That's what
he's That's always been the line on Charlie Kirk. You are literally
zogged. Charlie, you are you are the most zogged person in the
conservative movement. That's been Nick's opinion from moment
one. So that that's where it strays outside of understanding.
I understand why he's saying this right now, right? I understand
exactly why he's saying it, but this is just him lying at this
point. Disciplined person did not indulge in vices. a a family
man to see someone like this gunned down in cold blood in such
a cowardly act from such a distance like that in that moment
what was confusing before about our country what was divisive
before
where there was moral confusion
sorry just let this these donations go through private huff thank
you for the gifted sub we had we had three right two three uh
it's me ho thank you for the gifted sub and private huff thank
you for the gifted sub guys we got one sub carrying over to the
hour on the stream. Thank you. >> Rob fiscation, there
was clarity. And I don't care who you voted for. I don't care
what your politics are,
people white and black, men and women, feminists, conservatives,
people that are straight, people that are gay. I've saw across
Instagram, Tik Tok, a good deal of people, I hope the majority
in this country were shaken to their core because they saw true
evil. When the assassin's bullet cracked and the shot rang out
and people saw this young good man die for no good reason,
someone knowable to us. Every decent person that still has a
conscience, and I choose to use that word, everyone with a conscience
was able to say clearly that is evil. That is wrong. It >> yes
obviously true >> is wrong to violate the sanctity of life
in that way. Our lives are not our own. We belong to each other.
We belong to God. We do not create ourselves. We belong to our
creator. To see another human being, I don't care what they've
said in the past. I don't care what their opinions are. To see
someone sumearily executed in such a brutal way like that, there
was a moment of clarity where people saw, and this is an all
too familiar site, people saw evil and it shocked them to their
core. People saw true evil. weakness, cowardice, violence, hatred,
taking away someone who loved and was loved for no reason unjustly.
And people reacted with sorrow, outrage, anger, made people sick.
It shook people up because we were born with a moral law written
on our hearts. It's not just written in the Gospels. It's not
just written in the lives of the saints. It's also written on
our hearts. We know right from wrong. We know it when we see
it. We feel it. We feel it on a deeper level. It makes us physiologically
sick to see it. I think that's why it had such a profound impact.
And the reason that it has people so shaken up. Another reason
as I >> just to be clear, guys, you understand in-group
versus outgroup, right? Like the psychological like uh phenomenon
that happens when you're less empathetic to people in the out
group, more sympathetic to people in the inroup. He's describing
somebody in his in group being like executed in 4K in a way that
he could see, in a way that he sometimes like thinks about, you
know, himself going and doing kind of events like this.
It's it doesn't take very much imagination to understand why
conservatives are very upset over this, right? Versus the Pulse
nightclub shooting. It's just like obviously it's obviously it's
just obvious on its face. So you guys can keep saying, "Well,
what about these execution? What about these shootings?" It's
like, yeah, obviously this very different >> before
is because this is the middle of a very long story. >> Zeras
only understand things when it happens to them is my point. Uh,
that's just most people. That's like 99.9% of people. Private
Huff, >> as we all know, this did not come out of nowhere.
There were many events that precipitated this. We can talk about
the attempted assassination of Donald Trump last year when he
was shot in the ear and his display of strength of courage in
the face of a cowardly attack inspired millions of people, billions
of people around the world. They saw that little twerp, that
coward that climbed up on the roof and took a shot. And they
saw Trump in that moment who had nothing on his mind other than
that he needed to reassure his people.
show them he was not defeated or deterred. He rose up and raised
his fist, rallied the people to the side of strength, of goodness,
of righteousness. He survived by the grace of God. We saw it
when Luigi Manion gunned down the healthc care CEO months later.
>> What? And like the attack on Charlie Kirk yesterday.
Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. What did Nick think about
the Luigi thing? I actually don't in my head like while he would
be like oh murder's wrong I feel like that would be one where
he go but you know what these people are like bankrupting our
country the attack by Luigi Manion
was another chain reaction in that moment we saw a young man
a father a husband another innocent once again people say he
worked for some company he worked for an evil industry shot in
cold blood no trial no charge his life was not Luigi Manion Jones
to take and for some reason this divided the country. There were
millions of people that said he was a hero, treated him like
a icon, a champion.
They made t-shirts.
They celebrated. Is anybody surprised now that you have incidents
like this? Is anybody the least bit surprised in a culture where
mass murder and murder is celebrated? People cheer it on. They
lionize cowardly assassins and killers. Is any >> Oh, he's
uh he's losing me a little bit. He's losing me a little bit here.
I think um he's normally very good at walking the like populist
Christian line and he's although he's like correct. He's being
consistent. I think he is being consistent. I think that's the
one where he's supposed to identify with like the average person
who who feels like totally run down by society like they don't
have anything like they're losing like everything's becoming
worse, right? and he's getting away from that and that anger,
which is not normally something he does. So, I don't know if
he's got a wider angle here. We'll see. >> The least bit
surprised that it inspired a copycat. It inspired another. It
shouldn't come as a surprise. >> Is he calling the He's
calling the
Luigi Manion shooting a this shooting, the Charlie Kirk shooting,
a copycat of the Luigi shooting. >> But there's other echoes
of the violence that we saw yesterday. We saw it imminently just
the other week when that young girl, the Ukrainian refugee, was
stabbed to death on the train. We saw it when Austin Metaf was
stabbed in the throat. Oh. >> At a football practice. We
see it in Gaza for years
when innocent people are shot in the back of the head getting
food for their children because they're starving. The weight
of the suffering, the cruelty, the malice, the hatred, it's becoming
too much to bear. I think that's the real reason
because we've seen violence before. We've seen horrible atrocities
before.
We've seen school shootings, terrorist attacks.
But we all recognize we live in a time of nihilistic
violence. And it's coming from all sides. Nihilistic violence
perpetrated by barbarians
like these opportunists and predators. these young mostly adolescent
black men that are preying upon the innocent and the vulnerable
on city subways, city streets. We see it in the barbarism, the
predatory opportunistic attacks, executions,
random, cruel acts of violence. We see it in Zionism, dare I
say, in a certain strain of the Jewish
which says that the people of Palestine
>> dare I
say, dare I say, >> collectively responsible for the actions
of none of them are innocent. They all must die. And sitting
members of Congress like Randy Fine celebrates famine, starving
women, and children. Uh, so interestingly enough, he's pressing
forward without going for that block of people at all that would
be big Charlie Kirk fans, right? I I find that interesting. I
I know maybe people don't like this kind of analysis. He's um
that's that's going to put off a ton of the people who are big
Charlie Kirk fans. That that last bit of sentiment is going to
like totally shut them down. A million people under the age of
18 being blown to smitherines, being starved forcibly. We see
it in another form which is leftism. Communists, anarchists,
there is a certain strain of
For them, everything is political. Everything is ideological.
All this propaganda that's got them whipped up about fascism,
a trans genocide, about the health care system, they believe
the meaning of life is a political struggle, a political victory.
And so they have no love, no charity towards their opponents.
These are the different strains of nihilistic
coming from all angles that we've seen. And notice it comes from
everywhere. It comes from the political left. And by the political
left, I don't mean every Democrat. I don't mean every liberal.
I don't mean every Kamla voter. I mean a specific sect of the
radical left that recognizes no limiting principles. We see that
kind of nihilistic violence from a certain crowd of Zionists
and their allies. Some evangelical Christians. Oh, I just saw
this.
Oh, this was the uh this is some of the Infowars stuff that was
going on. There was some quote from Charlie Kirk. I couldn't
tell if it was AI where he was talking about how like like international
is responsible for funding transgender movements across the world
or something. It was something like that. Like it was Charlie
Kirk saying it was like oh what the it's like billionaires finance
this all over the world some like this right and and I wonder
if he's tapping into that like that thought there where it's
like oh they're allies like Israel's allies with these people
we see that kind of nihilistic violence from a certain crowd
of Zionists and they're allies some evangelical Christians atheistic
Jews that are sympathetic that wield immense influence in our
government and they want to wield our military against their
adversary. ies and we see it in the barbarians. We see it in
the unthinking,
primitive, backwards, regressive, you could say undeveloped
masses of people in other unenlightened parts of the world that
are coming here and visiting the savagery upon us. And if there
is anything that can come out of this, I hope that it can be
potentially a new consensus. This is not partisan. Actually,
it's not even ideological. People do not murder
children in a Catholic church
because they have gender dysphoria necessarily or they're sympathetic
to.
Somebody does not murder Charlie Kirk because they voted for
Kla Harris. People do not
young girls on trains because they're born black. People do not
Palestinians in the back of the head or cheer it on just be.
>> It's a lack of faith, right? It's a lack of religion
>> because you're the >> lack of it's a lack of connection
to Christ is what he's going to say, right? >> People that
do this are lost. They have to be isolated and segregated out.
A new consensus must emerge.
Are you in favor
of a society with meaning? A society where life is sacred, where
life has sanctity, where people's lives and their dignity and
their integrity is respected. >> Hold on. Somebody said,
uh, JTO being quieter during this than when Arerite says to be
nice. Um, I consider this person like dangerous politically.
Their thoughts are are like things that I'm concerned about like
spreading. Erodite is like a lull cow to me. I mean, she's she's
got some parts of her that are like actually probably quite bad
as well, but this person seems far more consequential to me.
So, when they when they speak, I'm like I'm actually listening
and trying to figure out like what direction they're going in.
>> Or are we going to live in a society that is a neverending
war between nihilistic tribes, warlords, savages, pagans? I see
an emerging consensus.
And I think that the mature people that actually love America,
actually love our children, the people that recognize the division,
the peril that we're in, we need to fortify a new consensus and
rally the people of conscience, the people of decency, the people
of humanity,
the people of charity towards their fellow man
against those that want to kill us, against those that laugh
and celebrate when innocent people are harmed. for any reason,
for any ideological reason, against the people that are cruel,
the people that are hateful. And by that I mean the people that
are really cruel, not the people that say things you disagree
with, not the people that are provocative, not the people that
are sometimes angry, but the people that are really cruel and
really evil. Uh he does do this thing, Holy War, Let's Go. He
does do this thing where he will move from
uh what would you call it? Like granular uh specific
put down your arms, guys. do not do not take up arms right now.
Do not fight. And then he will go higher level like uh he'll
zoom out and he'll go higher level and he will talk about the
people that need to be segregated out of society. He'll talk
about the ideologies that are poisoning society. And it's like
you you do say like don't fight people, don't hurt people, but
then you zoom you you zoom out. You go to a higher level. You
do talk about how these people are like inhuman. So it's it ah
man it gets I it doesn't always take violence but like I don't
think Nick's naive enough to think you can accomplish it without
violence
completely. Right. >> And let me be clear about this. >> That's
not what he's saying right now. Oh let's be clear >> because
I understand not a lot of people are loving this message right
now. This is not the message that a lot of people want to hear
right now. Here's another message he can try on for size. These
people that are now selling t-shirts with Charlie Kirk and a
bullet wound in his neck, they cannot be negotiated with. You
cannot debate with them. You cannot persuade them to vote Republican.
You cannot appeal to them. You will never convince them that
you're a good person, that you just want the best for everybody.
You will never get them to stop hating you. People like to say,
"Well, can the left finally admit that they have their own problem?"
They'll never admit that. They'll never admit that. The >> It's
just like, yeah, it's going to go in the totally opposite direction
now, isn't it? >> Is craven losers. That person person
that when Charlie Kirk got shot in the neck, instinctually got
up and turned and celebrated.
They have to be defeated. We can't change their minds.
We can't invite them to change our minds. We can't negotiate
with them. We can't invite them for a political compromise. If
your gut reaction to seeing someone take a bullet in the neck
and their face explode and their young children run up to them
because they were afraid of the noise, if your reaction was to
grin and celebrate, you must be defeated. You must be destroyed.
Okay, that's a little less uh implicit, right? That's a little
more explicit right there. Uh-oh. You must be destroyed. Uh-huh.
>> You must be identified. You must be isolated. And you
must be eradicated from our society. >> Uh-huh. Okay. Not
cool, man.
>> Not Democrats, not leftists, not liberals. Those people
that would celebrate in that moment. That is pure evil, pure
malice. There is no charity in a person's heart. I don't care
who it is who sees anybody get their neck exploded and celebrate
like that. That's the kind of evil we're dealing with. That's
the kind of evil that has taken over our society. It has become
too common. People have let it fester like with Luigi Manion.
They thought it was cute. They thought it was glib. And look
at what we have now. We are on the verge of full-on political
violence and civil war. I don't think people realize what that
looks like. There's going to be a lot of children without mothers
and fathers, a lot of mothers and fathers grieving their dead
children. I don't want that. Nobody should want that. But when
it comes to evil people, cowardly, weak, evil people that snipe
at Trump, at Charlie Kirk, like the gunman that came to my house
last year. Unfortunately, it's not always up to us
which battles we fight. When they show up to your front door,
when they take shots at the rally, at the change my mind, we
don't have a choice. We have to confront evil. We have to fight
evil. We can never give into evil and we have to win. Recognize
this. If these people ever get power over us,
these people
that celebrate, they sell t-shirts, they steal hats. When a man
is dude, the hat thing. Ah, I saw Masterson retweet the hat thing.
I was just like, "Bro, come on. I got this one black guy." You
guys know what he's talking about. The hat guy. Hold on. Dick
Masterson retweeted this. I was just like, "Dude, Dicker Masterson."
No, not the British one. the the Mexican one. Yeah, I got it.
I got it. I got it. I already had the Fentes thing on Luigi.
I've got it. I can look at it after
uh this guy. Oh, it's from AF Post 2. Like a black man went up
and stole a hat. Like throws somebody a hat and then he grabs
what? He grabs like another hat, throws it at somebody, and then
takes a hat. Like, okay. I just
>> let's go, guys. I don't know. Let's go. I have no idea.
Let's go. Come on, guys. >> What are you doing? Get the
[__] out.
>> Listen, Charlie would have wanted that. No. Well, listen.
Those are limited
>> Okay. Anyway, >> is lying dead. They will hurt
you. They will hurt your children. And they will destroy everything
that is sacred to us, everything that we love. And sorry, the
issue with bring up the hat right there is he's talking about
people who are celebrating the violence who are doing that broadly.
And then he added to the evil pile, the black dude who took the
hat, which I'm sorry, that guy does not rise to the level of
evil of the people taking the shots or the people celebrating
this guy dying, this father and and husband dying. To include
the black guy in there just feels weird to me. And they will
do it with a smile. They're already doing it. They have done
it. They're telling on themselves. And Sam Hyde said it very
well. All their cutesy language, their word games,
their sarcasm, their irony, it is dripping with malevolence,
dripping with contempt, dripping with malevolence and malice.
And if these people ever win, we will all suffer the same fate
as Charlie Kirk. They have to be defeated utterly and fundamentally.
Now, this is not a call to violence because taking up arms against
these people. How evil do you rate laughing at Kirk? 0 out of
10. Um,
no. Uh, I mean, it's up to just laugh at people's tragedies.
I understand people do it for like the edge effect of it, right?
I understand why people do it. Like, you're just being an edgy
boy. But if you actually if you actually like truly find it awesome
that this guy died in front of his kids, like there's probably
just something wrong with you. you're probably like an antisocial
person who can't really function in society. Like honestly, that
take is not that crazy. Like I'm sorry if you if you literally
are sitting here like, "Yeah, yeah, it's really cool that that
this guy died. Uh that you are just an antisocial person. Functions
like outside of society, but it is what it >> What will
that do? It will invite more of it. The Satanist, >> sorry.
When it's a coping mechanism, it's not your genuine thoughts.
It's a coping mechanism, right? That's I'm differentiating the
two. I'm saying if you genuinely feel like if you are just a
calm moment and you like we could just laugh at Charlie Kirk
and the the idea of him like getting shot in the neck, then you
are probably just somebody who can't function in society. You
are like an antisocial
reject who doesn't function with other human beings well and
so you find joy in the suffering of other human beings.
Yeah. Like the black pill guy, we know that he is that exact
thing, right? This guy is like totally antisocial. He doesn't
have friends. He doesn't have family. Doesn't have loved ones.
And this is like his revenge on the world as he can watch Charlie
Kirk die in front of his family.
>> The devil worshippers, the malevolent people that do
these things. In part, they do it to stoke
resentment,
to stoke conflict. They take the things that we love away from
us so that we will abandon God, so that we will become like them.
That is whether they know it or not. That >> uh Porter
Beller, you can totally be successful. I was saying antisocial
like you are engaging in really antisocial
>> Um there yeah I think so >> is why they do it.
That is why they are impelled to do it by spiritual supernatural
forces. I believe that. Do not mistake what I mean by defeat
them. And we'll talk about that more in a moment. But I want
to make that clear right now. This is not a call for violence.
Here is what I will say about left-wingers. Because a lot of
left-wing people reached out to me and they told me, "You have
a responsibility." They said, "We're afraid right now." They
said, "You need to lead people away from violence." I agree with
them, but where was that mentality
when someone showed up at my house with a gun and failed?
Those people were not reaching out then. Where was that mentality
throughout all of the persecutions, all the suffering? Now, this
is speaking from a place of resentment. They're afraid. They're
afraid that the right is going to punch back a thousand times
as hard. And we could and we can. And I fear that some might.
And I hope. No twisted rope. He's talking about the gunman who
came to his house and tried to kill him. Got killed by the cops.
There was a guy in a motorcycle helmet who came to his house
with a gun looking to kill him. to God that they don't. >> So
we're clear >> in some sense the right to be afraid. We
should all be afraid
that something we cannot control may happen. Here is what I will
say to those people. I and Charlie Kirk for years pushed a peaceful
resolution.
We invited the left to debate, negotiate. We played within the
system. When Obama told us you got to win elections, you know,
we tried that. And look at what they did to Trump. They shot
him in the head. We tried to do it your way. We tried to debate
to go to the the the polls, the voting booth. People ran for
office. And what did they encounter?
Intimidation,
menacing, harassment, slander, lies, assassination attempt.
Uh, I think other than the last one, I'm not totally sure, but
other than the last one, I feel like uh the Trump administration
is responsible for more of those things than any left-wing movement
that's happened, any even left of center movement at all in the
United States and successes. >> The Trump admin is the
are the people who are moving the the norms like down the field.
They're moving the football down the field constantly.
I >> now the left says we need to bring down the temp the
temperature. Here is what I would say to the left. The left now
has an obligation. You can turn down the
The left in America now, everybody in America now must come together
and disavow this nihilistic,
malevolent violence.
You all have an obligation. I have that obligation. And I I think
I have done it. I condemn the violence, all of it. all of the
nihilistic violence, whether it comes from the far right, the
far left, whether it comes from a Dylan Roof, the Buffalo shooter,
or someone like this. It's your job, too. You must condemn it
loudly. Loud enough that we can hear it, and you have to mean
it. We're going to just hit all of the points that you can clip
this out in different ways, and it could be like Nick fires up
the base and Nick Nick condemns the violence and Nick says Charlie
was a Titan and like it's just going to he's just going to hit
everything even though a lot of those things conflict. Charlie
would debate anybody. He was so committed to free speech. Wouldn't
never debate me though and cut me out of his movement and basically
got me banned from from what is it? CPAC and totally over my
career. But you know he's committed to free Okay. Okay. All right.
And I think of somebody like Hassan [__]
Such a hollow such a Hassan is bad. A hollow empty sad person.
Hassan [__] saw Charlie Kirk, someone that he knew,
get shot in the neck and his neck erupt with blood. We don't
need to be graphic about the details, but everybody should look
at that long and hard and let it sit with you. When Hassan saw
that, his first reaction was to make a glib remark about gun
control. Seriously? Was that his first? I thought his first reaction
to that was like staring at his screen in horror. He looked like
he he had been gutted. I thought pretty sure he looked at his
screen in like horror was like, "Holy, I can't believe that."
Like that's crazy. >> That's a 31-year-old man. That's
a young man with a wife and kids. He got shot in cold blood,
publicly executed in front of thousands of college students.
Never forget the trauma of his children, of his family. What
about the people that witness this? What about everybody that
will be affected by the knock-on violence that results from this?
And you hollow sick person, your response is to make some glib
remark about gun control. You
you and here's my message to Hassan [__] and every
liberal
like him.
>> You better disavow this violence. You better cry like
Dean Withers. And >> don't maybe that comes off like I'm
humiliating him.
Who knows whether that was sincere or not. I hope to God that
it was. And if it was, you know what? Good on him. That's a good
kid. And he said some nasty things about me. That's a kid with
a conscience. He said, "I don't think we should kill people for
disagreeing." Is that divisive now? He had to apologize for weeping
that someone he knew was >> Wait, did he apologize for
that? I think I cut Dean a lot of slack there. I listened to
Dean speak and I was like, you know, I get it. It's pretty [__]
up. I I can't imagine being like mad at Dean for crying there.
I don't know. It's like, dude, a lot of people see that stuff
and they just haven't watched like a lot of, you know, they didn't
grow up in the in the un monitored internet age. Okay, you you
born in like the 90s up until like maybe the early 2000s. Your
parents didn't really know the internet that well. You got to
go to sites like Live Leak and you got to see that you probably
should never have seen. Okay. Dean was not the person who saw
it in person. Spruce Willis, but yeah. Yeah, Dean was pretty
up. Uh, yeah. One to over Dean cried. Parker cried and then Dean
cried. Murdered.
That kid has a conscience. I have some faith in that generation.
Here's my message to Hassan and all these smug glib liberals
like that. If you cannot, if you will not disavow this violence,
we will have no choice but to consider you as no different than
the killers. That's complicity. You could be forgiven
up until this point for being irresponsible.
We all get heated. We all do it. I'm guilty of it, too. It makes
hypocrites of all of us. We murder each other with our words
all the time, with our gossip, our slander. We overreact. We
say things we don't mean. We get a >> man. This guy this
guy nailed the first like 20 minutes of this speech and then
he he went off the the wrathful end here at the end. And it's
just not I don't know. It's really it's really undercutting like
the first 20 minutes of the speech super badly. Angry. We harbor
grudges and resentment things that we should not. And that's
not to excuse it. But the day that someone gets shot for the
disagreement, if you can't bring yourself to show the slightest
ounce of humanity to a moderate to a moderate Republican who
got for no >> not a moderate Republican, dude >> reason.
This is a moment we all recognize. I obviously I obviously
disavow the violence, but threatening people into disavowing
the violence, that's not actually getting them to disavow. That's
not changing how they are. That's not changing anything about
them. that's just threatening them into disavowing. What are
you doing? >> Could set us down the path towards a civil
war. Could set us down the path towards unbelievable horror,
suffering, bloodshed. If you can't bring yourself even for this
for the selfish sake of yourself or your own people or your own
pathetic side to show the slightest ounce of humility, of mercy,
of magnanimity, benevolence, charity, then you are no better
than the killer. And that means that you must be destroyed politically
as well. That's not that was not Listen, he sometimes slips up
and has to add like destroyed politically. That that was like
pretty one one that was like destroyed politically. He was saying
destroyed politically the whole time. Okay. >> Then you
are no better than the killer and that means that you must be
destroyed politically as well. >> So like the the killer
should be destroyed politically. The guy who shot Charlie Kirk
in the neck, that guy should be destroyed politically. Is that
what we want? >> Oh, that's not a call to violence. But
people like that have to be suppressed. They should be censored
on the internet. They need to be named and shamed. And th this
is this is where I say what is what does victory look like? Here's
what it looks like in the short term.
This is a very delicate situation. This is a very delicate situation.
I fear that this has set off a chain reaction. I pray to God
there is no further violence.
I pray to God that nobody else is hurt as a result of this. I
hope that it it stops here. It should stop here. To all of my
followers, if you take up arms, I disavow you. I disown you in
the strongest possible terms. I that is not what we are about.
And the same goes obviously for the other side. And I want to
make that very clear. It would be a profound
moral
political mistake
for anybody to take the bait and to engage in any kind of reprisal,
retaliation, revenge. Remember, we are the good side. And what
makes us good is that we have Christ. >> He's now getting
back to like everything I said he should say, but he's he's like
cut out of this a couple times and gone and like actually said
that he thinks these people should be destroyed. And he's like
cut away from the actual message. I don't know why he didn't
I don't know how he got off book so hard on the message. >> What
makes Christianity and Christ so different from the other religions
is that our religion is based on the bearing of suffering for
the sake of even those that persecute us. An
of love.
An overflowing of self-giving love. So much of it it cannot be
contained and unconditional.
absolute standard of love for all of God's children. Even those
that are misguided, even those that persecute us, even the most
heinous among us, that is what makes us different. That is what
makes us good. You think you're good. You're not. You are not
good. I am not good. You are a man. I am a man. You are a sinner.
I am a sinner. We cannot save ourselves. We cannot save this
world. God can save us. God can save the world. And God saves
us. And God saves the world by drawing all of us up onto the
cross with him. And we join not just in his glory, but in his
suffering, real suffering, not imaginary, not a nice story. Real
suffering, real death, real destruction, real misery.
We bear a cross like Christ bears a cross, like his disciples,
like the martyrs, like the saints bear a cross. And you better
get comfortable up there. Drink up. And you bear that cross.
Not for your kin, not for yourself, not for your children, which
are an extension of yourself.
You bear that cross and that suffering. You drink from that chalice
for your enemies, for those that persecute you, for those that
hate you for the sake of Christ. That doesn't mean we let them
hurt us. It doesn't mean we let them take over our country, but
it does mean that we do not lower ourselves to their level. It
does mean that we do not resort to our own powers, our own machinations,
our own plans, our own pride with vengeance, with retaliation.
Vengeance belongs to God. God is both merciful and just. And
no one can say they have faith in God if they do not have faith
in God's perfect justice
which we cannot understand which is hard to accept sometimes
impossible but that's what it is to be a Christian that's what
it was like to be the first Christians he had me in the beginning
but his attacks on the left are incoherent are incoherent without
an acknowledgement of the ongoing violence from the right and
I think he's acknowledged that ongoing violence he's talked about
the Trump administration cracking down on free speech he's talked
about a lot of those things so it's interesting interesting that
he won't incorporate any of that, right? Although that will seem
like justifying to all of his to his entire audience. So like
that will seem like he's justifying on the behalf of like lefties
or non non-Trump followers. Um this isn't really world word salsa,
but I think you need to understand a little bit more about Christianity
to get where he's going with some of the things he's saying.
Now I don't think this is I don't think this is like uh nonsensical.
I think people who are obviously most of you guys would be atheists.
you just wouldn't understand this at all. >> To watch God
himself nailed to a cross for the sake of everyone. You cannot
tell me you have faith in God if you don't have faith that all
of those people that seek to hurt us will ultimately meet their
divinely appointed justice at God's hands, but not our own. Those
lives are not ours to take.
No, I understood where he was going with this kosher. I understood
from the very beginning where he was going with this part where
he talks about the the chalice and and and the suffering you
have to endure. I could tell he was saying that it's not your
right to to try to take revenge to try to take to have vengeance
on people. I can tell where he was going. I'm just guessing most
of the audience can. >> In the meantime, >> don't
feel really comfortable. >> How do we defeat these people
so that they cannot hurt us? We have a right to exist. We have
a right to defend ourselves. And this is going to be a consistent
theme here. The first thing that we need to do and and everybody
needs to be on the same page here.
Right, left, middle, I I am calling on everybody today. Today
we are all
today. We are all Christians in that we want the cycle of retributive
ju uh vengeance and violence to stop. In that sense, today we
are all Christians whether culturally, religiously, we are all
Americans. We all want to see our country pull through. We all
want to see our loved ones survive.
Liberal or conservative, we all want to be around for the next
Christmas. We all want to see our children graduate college in
the spring. I'm calling on everybody. We all have uh a place
in this. Everybody must condemn this violence. You don't need
to condemn Kla Harris. You don't need to condemn liberalism.
You don't need to condemn whatever issue it is. You must condemn
the violence at the minimum. The nihilistic violence has to stop.
And today I would stand like any other day, shouldertoshoulder
with any one of my enemies, any one of them. anybody that that
ordinarily
they would think I would find them disgusting. You know, somebody
who I least expected, I'm not even going to say who it is. You
would not believe.
Somebody hits me up and says, "I'm the exact kind of person you
would absolutely hate. I don't hate anybody, but that person,
all these people have to be joined up for the sake of America,
for the sake of humanity, and say we disavow the nihilistic violence.
It is intolerable in our society. It must be absolutely
suppressed, suffocated. It has to be snuffed out.
The light has to defeat the darkness. The day after this death,
the left, the right, everybody must say this has to stop. It
should be an easy bar to clear. And for those that don't, I think
I speak for everybody when I say for the people that are interrupting
the vigils for the young man who was then and yelling Charlie
Kirk, for the people that are selling t-shirts, mocking his execution,
for the people that are saying he deserved it for some such other
reason. These people must be ostracized from our society. We
must identify them. We must have them fired from their jobs.
They must be censored on social media. There must be a cop. >> I
wonder I wonder a little bit if he watched the Asmin Gold video.
I I feel like he understands. Yeah, I feel like he understands
a little bit about >> because if there isn't, this will
continue. If there isn't, their ridicule, their pro provocations,
their antagonism, it will provoke more violence. It will spawn.
It will generate more violence. Copycats.
Those people must be named. They must be shamed publicly. They
must be penalized. Don't hurt them. Don't give them the satisfaction.
Don't make them martyrs. Don't stoop to their level. But that
guy who laughed when Charlie Kirk was shot, this guy needs to
answer for why he did that. This guy should not be able to find
a living. This guy should not be able to find harbor. Let him
crawl on his belly across this country finding no refuge because
people that are complicit in evil like that do not belong in
a decent society. That black individual
that jumped over the fence and started stealing MAGA hats while
Charlie Kirk was dead in an ambulance or in an SUV. That guy
needs to be named and shamed, too. Is nothing sacred? Does anything
matter? Is there any humanity? How dare you? How dare you? We
will not cannot live in a society with people like that. >> I
just feel like that's like me for the for like his base in a
way that just doesn't make any Why compare that to the people
celebrating the death?
It's >> somebody like that and shamed. They must hang their
head in shame until there is some repentance on their side. Fortunately,
our religion believes in forgiveness.
But there must be a penance here. You you have to say you're
sorry. You have to be penalized in some way. This cannot go unanswered
anymore. That's what happened when Luigi Manion that guy. That's
what happened when Trump got shot and everybody made fun of it.
Yeah. It's grabbing souvenirs at a murder scene is ghoulish.
It absolutely is. I'm just saying it's not comparable to people
celebrating the guy dying or um to the shooter comparable to
the shooter. There's got to be some differentiation between these
different levels of crimes, right? to put them all in the same
bucket is just weird. >> How many more times does it have
to happen?
Everybody is accountable to say this does not have a place in
our society and we must shame the people that think this is okay.
This is not okay. And if you think it is, what kind of society
are we going to live in? Is that how we solve our problems? We
kill each other. Well, but Charlie Kirk said this. Okay. Well,
we disagree with you. Should we go and you in your house? What
are what is our country going to become? Who's going to run our
country? The toughest warlord. Where do you think that goes?
This is how you solve
You get a gun like a coward and sneak up behind someone and him
in the head. Um, Destiny and XC are going at it. Okay. To name.
Are you trying? Are they going at it for like biggest falloff
of the year 2025 or who gives a >> And then what? They
don't like you, so they're going to do it to you, and you do
it back. And pretty soon, we have a country that's run by warlords.
We have rule by the most brutal, the most cruel, the most malevolent.
Nobody wins in a society like that. After millions of corpses
are stacked up, we will be celebrating the death of someone making
the life of billions worse, isn't that bad. I mean, Charlie Kirb's
got a tenuous connection that is difficult for most people to
understand, that most people don't understand. I would say it's
not sorry it's not a tenuous connection to most people it seems
like a tenuous connection right most people don't understand
it so when you when you just celebrate this guy's death you say
oh well he really sucked he like he he was like directly involved
in like policy make decision-m people won't understand that right
you got to have some understanding that most people won't see
it'll be ruled by the most brutal tyrant you could ever imagine
is that the kind of society you want to live in that's where
this is headed obviously and in some sense the left is right
to be scared because the right is more proficient in violence.
The left is more willing, the right is more capable. What do
you think happens in a civil war? You already see the cruelty
of some people on the right. You know, I'm sure there are people
on the left that are saying, "Is this really what the left needs?"
Is another pro liberal someone bringing down heat on all of them?
Good luck. You know, it's it's like the Dark Knight. You're telling
me that Donald Trump is a billionaire? I just don't I don't know.
The right lost the last civil war. Um, is that even accurate?
Would that be like the right wing? I'm trying to think of like
the differences between the two groups. Wouldn't like the pro
liberty party be the people who wanted to extend liberty to all
of the
Who's also secretly a fascist racist empowered by palunteer and
AI surveillance and your job is to dare that administration to
create tyranny? you know, and I not to sound glib or whatever,
but this is what we're talking about. So, there must be a new
consensus that this kind of >> Yeah. I just don't see it
as a leftright divide. I don't think it like maps onto existing
like political
discourse in a way that makes any sense. Also, even if that were
true, which it I don't know if that is true, but even if it were
true, it's kind of like a like, yeah, when when we had musketss,
um the right-wing lost like okay, it's been a long time since
then. inhuman,
uncharitable,
hateful nihilism. It has to be the scourge of our society. We
have to do our part to drive it out. And you know what the best
way to do that is other than the obvious, which I already see
people doing. And you know what? Good. I see people getting these
people fired. I see people h holding these people accountable.
And good on them. Our strongest weapon is to shine. Our strongest
weapon, if you, as I said, really believe in God, it's not a
gun. It's not some some other weapon of choice.
Our strongest weapon is the power of prayer. And I and I know
that's taken a lot of heat. I know there's a lot of cynical,
arrogant people that think they know better. They say thoughts
and prayers. When you put your intentions
and your consciousness
and your conscience in alignment with the true and living God,
the God of mercy, the God that is synonymous with love, the God
that is synonymous with truth and charity, it will shine through
your actions. It will shine through your words and your deeds.
And it will shine for others to follow. It will shine for other
people that are misguided, other people that are confused, other
people that may be considering evil things. Everybody's looking
for some tyrant to save us. People are looking for a militia
to save us. They're they're looking for a militant Messiah
to deliver us from our enemies so that we can rule and things
can be the way we want them to be. But that Messiah already came.
His kingdom is within. His kingdom is above outside of this.
You want to make society better, it starts with you.
And the cardinal sin, the first mist
uh I think if Nick wanted to monologue the whole thing, which
it seems like you did. I I feel like he made the Trump mistake.
Okay. You just wanted to give a speech, you should have kept
it to like an hour. All right. You go two hours on on the same
speech. This is a It's incredible that he can do it. Okay. guy's
like talented to be able to do it, but he's he's really we've
he's like woven all over the map with this in a way that I it's
hard to keep the whole has not been consistent here. It's just
been like a really all over the map. It sounds good. He's very
compelling as a speaker. But if you are actually listening, which
I am, it's it's weaving >> mistake you can make is to think
that in a fundamental way, in an essential way that we're different
from the people that hate us. It's not to say that we're killers.
It doesn't make us killers. But we have a fallen nature. We have
a tendency to love ourselves.
We have a tendency to believe in
We're prone
to the appetites of the flesh, the emotions,
supernatural forces. If you don't want that to win, you must
resolve in your heart first what side you're on in the spiritual
battle. Are you on the side of God? Talk to God. Pray to God.
Give your intentions to God. Align your will with God. That's
how you know you're on the right side and not on the side of
if you're out there thinking about revenge and talking tough
and war and all this stuff. I would say think again. Now, here's
the other part. We are in a civilizational struggle. People say
obviously we're in peril. We have a real problem on our hands.
We are besieged
from every corner by the devil and by the devil's allies. as
I said, by this elite syndicate which runs our country. It runs
off of drug money. It runs off of violence and terrorism. It
supports heinous wars and bloodshed like in Palestine.
We're also besieged not just from above, but from below by barbarians,
by a primitive form of evil, by bandits, savages, murderers.
You see it all the time, like we saw last week. You see it from
our ideological opponents from from people in the middle, intellectuals,
academics, these arrogant intellectuals chroling to themselves
about this atrocity. They all have to be defeated. They will
not be defeated by random acts of violence like some people are
thinking of. They will not be defeated today, tomorrow. People
say, "What are we going to do? We got to get out there." How
did Christ win the victory over the Roman Empire? How did Christ's
church grow from 12 to millions
to take over
the ancient known world? They didn't expand by the sword. They
didn't expand by conquest. It was by the witness.
Witness to their true faith. Witness to their suffering. When
the Roman soldiers came to arrest Christ, the first instinct
of his disciples was to defend Christ, to attack. >> Money
Morgan, have you been listening to this? I just I feel like you
are missing. There are parts of this that could be good. If you
listen to the right 20-minute section, this could win over any
audience on the right wing. He's just hoping that those people
only seek out the sections they want to see, right? He's he's
appealed to like five different groups that all have like over
uh that all have like conflicting views on how the right should
move forward. And Christly admonished his disciple Peter and
said, "Those that live by the sword perish by the sword. Trade
your sword for a cloak. Be as clever as a serpent and as innocent
as a dove. This is my message. Every young adolescent man watching
this, everybody whipped up, boomers too, boomer waffin that's
out there, ev every
person that is outraged by this, every person that wants change,
I give you the same message. Trade your arms for a cloak. Be
as clever as a serpent, as innocent as a dove. Write your interior
life. Write your conscience. Put your conscience and your attentions
in alignment with God. Be as innocent as you can be. Try your
best to live a moral life, but don't be stupid.
Don't be naive. With Charlie Kirk's death, his Turning Point
organization, the fate of it is uncertain. >> It's not
I don't I don't even think Charlie Kirk I think Charlie Kirk's
a face, but I don't think Charlie Kirk is like the uh that that
that organization's going nowhere. That organization is way too
important to way too many people to go anywhere. >> Charlie
Kirk, I'm going to be honest with you. I saw him as an establishment
figure. I saw him as too moderate. We must fill up the ranks
of these campus organizations with Septemberist.
>> You didn't see him as too moderate. You saw him as like
a Trump who a
That's what you saw him as. You didn't think he was moderate.
You thought he probably had some beliefs similar to you. But
he would when push came to sell when push comes to shove, when
rubber meets the road, Charlie Kirk would sh would suck the Israel
or suck the Trump over actually maintaining his morals. That's
how Fuentes saw Charlie Kirk. He just doesn't want to say it
now. >> Forget about the free market. Forget about pro-Israel
free market. Whatever. It is incumbent on all adolescent young
men that want to save this country that want any future for your
children that want to preserve what your ancestors built
to get involved in politics and to do more. And when I say politics,
do not mistake what I mean. I don't mean go and vote for more
Republicans to bomb Palestine. I do not mean to vote for more
Republicans to cover up the Epstein files. Vote for more Republicans
to squander and botch something like this so badly as they have.
I mean, you need to become a human Swiss Army knife. Become unkillable.
I'm not this guy, but get in the gym. Get in the gym. Do tactical.
Okay. Okay.
What? Shut the up, Nick. You cannot do this one. This is the
one he can't do. No, Nick. No. No way. Training become hard to
so you can protect yourself and your family. Learn the rules
of the game and use them to your advantage. Get involved in politics.
Get involved in a campus organization tomorrow. Get involved
in a campaign. Not with the mind towards I'm going to put up
stickers. Not with a mind towards we're going to get the vote.
with a mind towards we are in this struggle until we die by any
means. We are in this struggle for the long haul. Until we win,
none of us are safe. None of our families are safe. We will keep
being attacked. Get used to it. You'll see more of it. I hope
we don't. I pray that we don't, but we will. Get involved for
the people that can't. For the people that aren't with us, for
the people that aren't able. Start your career now so that one
day you can be in a position of real power.
real money, real influence, real government power, and not today,
not tomorrow. Because listen, that's not how these things happen.
Rome is not built in a day. This kind of societal change, people
that are looking for a quick fix. What are we going to do? You're
not going to like the answer because it is not that we are going
to go out
in some climactic, ecstatic, orastic,
violent action like a movie. That's that never delivers change.
and never delivers anything good. What does deliver real change
is the thankless, monotonous,
boring task, the oftentimes not very rewarding task of going
in day in day out and dealing with logistical problems and frustrations
and fighting every day so that we can be in charge, so that we
can protect our country, our inheritance,
and all people.
This these talking points are kind of why I think it's unlikely
that Groper was the person like responsible for this is because
this is almost always the message he gives his followers, right?
Is like don't go do like flashy don't start talking about don't
start talking about any of this. Go and get a position on a campaign.
Go become somebody who has influence somewhere. Do not give these
beliefs away. Do not tell people about these beliefs. You are
going to infiltrate. You're going to be somebody. And then once
you're at the top, then you can start actually like moving policy
in the right direction. It's never like, oh, go be as like uh
go be as, you know, flamboyant as possible, make a big like splash,
go do some crazy [__] It's always the opposite. Is
like consistently what he hits. This is probably the closest
I've seen him to saying like some about, oh, you like lefties
need to apologize or you're going to be in trouble. I've I He
almost never does that. >> That's the solution. That's
my call on all people in the short term. This scourge in our
society, it must be driven out. It must be suffocated by goodness.
They must be shamed, not hurt, not injured, not
>> I think he does. People don't think he doesn't think
the revolution is going to work. He doesn't think a revolution
could work. So, he'll like be there and he would be down for
it. I just think he he believes that's never going to
>> But they must be shamed. They must be ostracized. They
must they we cannot associate with these people anymore. And
a more voluntary action is you need to get involved. This is
the call to action that you're not going to like sadly. And I've
been around for a long time and I've seen it and you may not
believe me. I've seen enough of these instances. You know how
this goes. He did not think January 6th was it. He tried to go
to the stop. He did all the stop the steel rallies. He didn't
even stay for when they stormed the capital. If he thought January
6th was it, why didn't he stay for when they stormed the capital?
I don't know. I don't know why people think that that's the case.
Why would he leave hours before they stormed the capital building?
>> Everybody's paying attention now because they saw the
gory video. Everyone's in their feelings because they saw
video edits and productions with music on them on TikTok.
But in two weeks, everybody's going to be right back to their
regular old lives. You know that that's the best case scenario.
Everybody's going to be right back to their ordinary lives in
a year. Sadly, I hate to say this, and we won't let them forget,
but many will forget. Many people need to be reminded. And that's
typically how these things go. Use the anger. Use the emotions
you're feeling now. Not to ruin your life. Not to say something
reckless, do something you regret, not to say something ju just
as murderous as what happened, or do something just as evil as
what occurred. Take these emotions, transmute them. Align your
intentions with God. Use it for a righteous cause.
Use it to get involved in a generational struggle. This is not
me telling you not to act. On the contrary, dedicate your life
to this. Dedicate your life to taking over our country
to deliver a real victory. There is no substitute. There is no
alternative. They must lose.
We must win. They must be defeated. Ultimately, we must win.
We must control the halls of power. We must control the big guns.
We must control society
for the good of us, our families, for the good of our enemies,
for their own good, for the good of the children that have grown
up and been misguided and corrupted by the devil and his allies
to become this, to become monsters for the good of us all. That
is our responsibility. That's my message. Do with it what you
will. We're not going to read super chats tonight. What happened
yesterday cannot be undone. And and a word on life and death.
Here's the thing. There's only one way out of this world. Major
reason this was so disturbing,
so depressing. >> Wouldn't be a good strategy
if Nick unites with Hassan because both are basically commies
and hate tiny hats.
Uh this is a incredibly incredibly um uninformed comment. I don't
know. blessing is because we saw it right up close and personal.
And and here's the thing about death. It's not pretty.
It's not glorious.
It's not triumphant. No one is triumphant in their death other
than Christ. We die weak, feeble,
mentally, physically incapacitated,
violently.
You see how fragile life really is. A bullet rips through your
neck, it's over in an instant. How fragile the balance between
life and death really is. how short and unpredictable life really
is. We have plans.
We have schedules, routines. We have a fate, an appointed day,
when we will be sentenced to death one way or another. Somehow
eventually it will take us by surprise and then we will spend
eternity in heaven or hell. Remember that you will die. Like
Charlie Kirk, you and I will die. Charlie Kirk had plans. We
all have plans. We all have plans to live to be 95 years old,
retired with our family on our side, dying of old age, peacefully
in our sleep. That's not promised. None of it. None of it is
promised. Not our bodies, not our faculties,
not our cognitive capabilities, not not 50 years, not tomorrow,
not today, not tonight.
Do with that information what you will. Live as though if you
die, >> bro. Are DJers like actually um are DJs actually
coming in here and getting mad that I'm not reacting to Destiny?
I don't care. It's boring. I don't give a [__] At
any moment, you'll be satisfied with it. And what do we take
with us in death? We don't take any of it. Not our bodies, not
our wealth, as you know, not our esteem, our credibility, our
our victories.
All of it eventually be washed away by time and by eternity.
What you take with you to the judgment are your deeds. What is
melted down at the end of your life is your actions. And they
will be melted down like metals.
And they will be gold, silver, bronze, copper. They will be judged
accordingly to their weight, to their kind, to their type. What
did you do? Did you do the right thing? Did you tell the truth?
Did you sacrifice
as Christ did? Did you do these things as Christ did? In the
end, that is all that you take with you and it is worth its weight
and gold. Literally, people get so caught up. They're so worried
about strategy, machinations, all even the fate of our people
here in this world. But the world is passing. We are passing.
We are mortal. And all these people that see Charlie Kirk and
I get it. People are beating their chest. They don't want to
be deterred. They don't want to be defeated. Let it be a reminder.
We all die. Ashes to ashes, dust to dust. We're all going that
way. And the least that you could say about Charlie Kirk is that
he died
professing a faith in God. He died professing the truth. Let
us be so lucky. In a way, I don't count him as lucky. It's a
it's a horrible tragedy.
years taken, memories, but ultimately martyed for the sake of
the truth, for the sake of mercy, for the sake of the unborn,
for the sake of children affected by all these diabolical, perverse
things. He will receive a handsome reward in heaven for it. May
he rest in peace. God bless Charlie Kirk, his his family, his
>> Oh my God, I think we're at the end. >> Everybody
think we're here finally. his enemies, his his friends, everybody
in the country. Let us truly see each other as children of God.
Let let us all see God in everybody.
Let's be charitable towards one another in our words, in our
actions.
Let's be slow to anger. And I know it's rich for me to say that.
I'm a very volatile person. Let us be slow to be angry, wrathful,
vengeful, judgmental. Let's try to be kind, >> so wrathful
in his understanding, but at the same time, let us be strong,
tough, >> like he's he's literally wrathful in the >> clever
when we need to be. Let us defend the people we love from those
that are trying to hurt us. And God, give us the strength, the
prudence,
the perseverance to defeat this evil with some finality in our
lifetimes. And it may be a long time, but let us see it through
to the end for for the sake of everybody. That's Charlie Kirk.
So, go God bless him. Rest in peace. And uh I I hope you'll take
this message to heart. I know there's going to be a lot of people
out there and they're going to say, "We need extremism. We need
violence. We need to take matters into our own hands." Do not
listen to them. Do not listen to the diabolical.
Resist the temptation. That's my final admonition to all of you.
But that's all I have for you. That's my show. I appreciate everybody
for joining me. Thank you everybody that tuned in. Um, and I
I do take seriously my role. I don't want to say anything inappropriate.
It's not necessarily about me, but at this point it's unignorable.
It's been thrusted upon me. As you know, throughout my time doing
this,
I think this just happens if you try to do a two-hour speech.
Like a two-hour sermon is
really difficult. Uh, I you just the the weaving was a I don't
know. That's not what I That was an opportunity and he hasn't
squandered very many opportunities recently. Guys, obviously
been growing massively, but I I feel like this one was a little
squandered. >> Uh I have been dismissed, attacked. You
know, I had an article written about me the other day. They described
me as a >> These people must be destroyed. But also, guys,
put down your arms.
And the left needs to apologize or else you know what happens.
We have to treat you like the killers. And also be be innocent
as a dove. Like I Okay. What? What? >> I recognize that
I have an obligation now to be serious. I recognize that I and
so many of you too, we we have to be leaders. And what it means
to lead, not only to lead by example, but it also means to resist
our worst inclinations for the sake of the common good. Not what
feels right, not what feels good for us in the moment, not what
satisfies
our anger, but what is truly best. It takes vision. It takes
courage. It takes prudence. It takes leadership. We need people
to grow up. We need people to fill in to that role. And I hope
that people watching the show will do that. I hope people heed
my warning. And I pray for the country. So >> only could
if only Wood if only Wood could be as consistent and righteous
as you, Jay Talk. I don't claim to be that. I don't claim to
be a thought leader. I'm not stepping into the position he is,
obviously.
>> God bless Charlie Kerr. God bless all of you, our country,
and I will see you on Monday. I don't think I'll do a show tomorrow.
I think I'll be back on Monday. So, that's all I have. >> The
most important part of Charlie Kirk's death is Nick gets two
days off in three days. Sorry. In five in five days, he gets
two days off. Okay? He's taking some time off, right? >> I
for you. Be safe out there. Protect everybody. Be vigilant. These
are some scary and disturbing times. But I will see you later.
Ordors, are you just mad that you misspelled you like uh spilled
your spaghetti the second you tried to be clever? Are you good?
Okay, you can take a week off. You can be back in a week. Good
luck >> everybody. Signing off. Let me awkwardly produce
this ending here. God bless everybody. I will see you next week.
Thank you very much for listening. >> I'll see you next
week. God bless.